e
e e
morning everybody we'll get going just
about another two or three
minutes
e e
okay now that representative stavis is
finally here we will be
good morning everybody um before we get
going we will uh have representative
Guthrie lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance thank you representative
excuse
me uh we'll call a roll here in just a
second just so everybody knows we have
representative elberger joining us today
in Municipal and County government
welcome she is here in replacement of
Representative with that we'll ask the
clerk to call a
rooll vice chairman power here represent
Guthrie K is here representative lales
here representative ukel representative
Kelly here representative awood here
representative Brown here representative
kill here representative stavis here
representative
Tetro representative alberger here
representative majori here
representative Gallagher here
representative Hicks here representative
Howland here representative priest here
representative Frack here and chairman
to C
here okay thank you Mr clerk uh good
morning everyone we are here this
morning we have a bunch of uh bills we
are going to exact before we start we'll
just I want to talk to two of them um
the last one on our list
1180 that one we will not be executing
today um there's
been
multiple drafts and things going on
behind the scenes and I actually had a
discussion with one of the uh attorneys
that was involved with the Supreme Court
case that actually brought this on I had
a discussion yesterday so we we've got a
ways to go on that one the other one
that we will
be uh waiting on is
1124 that's a very extensive bill that
um the prime sponsor uh has been working
with uh n Grace with the nhma to get it
into a final disposition one that is uh
um 100% correct and complete so those
two we will not be doing today besides
that all the other ones we intend to
proceed on so with that we'll open up
the executive committee hearing on hb1
1242 relative to the establishment of
countywide communications
District uh I see that represented
um do I have a motion on that Mr chair
I'd like to make a motion if I may go
ahead uh I'd like to move ought to pass
on House Bill 1242 and with your
permission to speak to the motion if
it's seconded do we have a second
representative stavis second it uh go
ahead thank you Mr chairman um uh HB
1242 which is about establishing
communication districts in counties uh
to the best of my research into the RSA
and as we uh learned in the public
hearing uh the RSA 53 oh I forgot the
number uh
53g um allows for municipalities to
create communication districts this bill
will extend that to uh counties uh that
will be able to create communication
District it's enabling legislation
obviously if uh if County then are
working uh similarly to
municipalities uh and have uh larger uh
buying groups uh there's an economy of
scale which then can hopefully uh enter
into contracts which benefit all the
residents of the County uh and extend
this kind of service uh which is much
needed uh which is needed all over the
place uh to the residents at hopefully
what would be a more affordable cost I
would hope that the committee would
agree with ought to pass motion and
that's all I have Mr chair men chairman
you're not a chair you're a chairman
chairman
whatever do we have any further comments
representative
power thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting against the recommendation of a
to pass I feel that this bill is not
needed countywide communication
districts can already be established
under
RSA and for example Carol County has um
established a communication District um
under in back in
2023 I I I don't like the idea that this
is um being approached from the the
inverse Direction Where municipalities
would have to opt out I would prefer
that the legislation stays um the
statute stays as it as it currently is
thank you
further comments representative
Gallagher um so I'd just like to um note
that straford County feels that this is
necessary and um if the
existing uh method of all municipalities
coming together to form a countywide one
were sufficient for them they wouldn't
have requested this but they did so I
think um that shows that is in fact
needed and I just like to thank the
prime sponsor uh Heath Howard for his
work on this um important issue and I'll
be voting in favor of it further
comments representative
PR thank you Mr Speaker I will also be
voting in favor of this bill because I
think it's long overdue especially in
the rural uh communities of our state
and counties that are thly lacking in
communication um um
infrastructure thank
you further
comments seeing thatone I'll make a
couple um I I will Echo what chairman
power
said the uh biggest reason I I I can't
vote for this is it allows a single
County to basically declare their County
of communications District uh
representative Gallagher brought up the
the uh issue of straford County um for
the same reason he thinks it should be
it's the exact reason why it shouldn't
be we everybody here is well aware of
what's going on in straford County um in
terms of districts
and
having right now until the next election
having the ability of straford County to
declare themselves a communication
District without any
checks and balances is just not
acceptable to me as uh chairman power
said also coming at it from the wrong
direction where you have to opt out
rather than opt in it's just not the way
to go so I will also be voting against
it further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call a
rooll vice chairman in power no
represent of Guthrie no click votes no
represent
no represent yella representative Kelly
no represent awood no representative
Brown no Representative kahill no
representative stavis
yes repres T representative
elberger
yes represent majori yes representative
Gallagher uh yes representative Hicks
yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack yes and Mr chairman
no motion fails 9 to8 do I hear another
motion representative uh kill thank you
Mr chair I'd like to make a motion of
itl on hb1
1242 thank you do I have a second on
that representative power
seconds any further
discussion seeing none we'll ask the
clerk to call the
roll uh Vice chairman power yes
represent of Guthrie yes click votes yes
representative sales yes representative
Ella representative
Kelly representative Kelly I'm sorry I
didn't hear you ma'am representative
awood yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes Representative
stavis
no representative Tio uh Representative
elberger
no representative okay majori no
representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
representative Holland no representative
Priest No representative Frank no Mr
chairman yes motion pass pass is
928 okay I assume this will not go on
the consent calendar uh representative
power we'll write the committee report
for the itail motion and representative
majority yes sir we'll write the
committee report Was the vote I couldn't
hear
98 okay and with that what's that
uh representative majority will be
writing the report for you
guys with that we'll close the hearing
on HB or the uh exact session on 12:42
[Music]
okay with that we will go ahead and open
up an executive session on hp1 1250
enabling the creation of certain Village
districts um do we have a motion
representative
stavis thank you Mr chair I'd like to
move on to pass on hb1
1250 and to speak to my motion thank you
do we have a second second
representative majori second
representative stavis go ahead thank you
again Mr chair um village districts are
a time-honored tradition in New
Hampshire they they help
to um Safeguard and protect and preserve
valuable Assets in the states that in
the state that um
municipalities would have no other way
of protecting as a as a
community
um and our bodies of water are
particularly vulnerable to uh harm right
now from over fertilization and other
activities um I know where I live in
Lebanon we Face many many tens of
millions of dollars of remediation every
year and cyanobacteria blooms and our
only source of drinking water which is
Lake Mascoma which spans
municipalities so to have uh the ability
to have a village District to protect a
body of water that is so vital to so
many people roughly 14,000 people um
would be a great asset to the state and
so I fully support this the passage of
this Bill thank
you thank you further
comments representative
power thank you Mr chairman I will be
supporting the motion of a to pass on
House Bill
1250 um I would agree with my colleague
in her comments and I would also add
that there are numerous studies economic
studies that show that as water quality
decreases on a body that the property
owners AB buding that body of water
their their property values will in fact
decrease so it's in the interest of
people who live who have Shoreline
property to work together to prioritize
the the health of the body of water and
I feel that you know this enabling um
legislation is a tool in the toolbox for
people to come together um to address
the issues um surrounding bodies of
water representative Brown uh I will be
voting against this bill I recently sat
in as a substitute for the environment
agriculture committee uh and they've
move they're moving forward with a bill
to address the concerns in regard to
over Fertilization in The Lakes areas so
that's one of the reasons why I'm going
to be voting against it and there's
other complications as far as I'm
concerned as well so thank you further
comments representative major thank you
Mr chairman I'll be voting in favor of
the aop pass motion as I've uh learned
from the prime sponsor in his area and
the communities in his area have uh
created have created a model which if
this bill passes other communities will
be able to mirror as a as a best
practice for how to implement this to
protect their their uh their their water
bodies and so not only do I think the
bill is a great idea I'm also confident
that we have a model which can be
mirrored uh to help all communities in
the State uh duplicate this so um I'll
be voting in favor thank
you further comments representative
priest I will thank you Mr Speaker Mr
chairman um I will also be uh supporting
this bill uh I think it's long overdue
and I think one thing that is very
crucial to all of our existence is water
and once that water is polluted um it's
gone and it's going to be very costly to
bring it back up and this is one tool to
to monitor it and to protect it thank
you
further
comments represent Elward is your hand
up or just no okay any others seeing
another no others I will make uh couple
comments um I will also be voting um
against this for probably a little bit
different reasons um I am a actually a
property owner on the water in Maine um
for during the summer but I I have to
say
that this
particular I see this as particularly
um obnoxious uh for par for some from
some land owners and I I just want to
read from some of the testimony written
testimony that was given in first we got
to recognize what this
allows towns and municipalities to do is
designate
specific properties to be part doesn't
have to be Waterfront it could be a
Mountaintop piece of land that maybe
drains into a lake or
stream and the problem with that is yes
it goes to the voters but you could have
51% of the
voters Within These
districts put their desires
over the 49% who vote against
it and this is a problem
because as I'm reading from one of these
testimonies districts for the enactment
of rules and
regulations uh which would not apply
elsewhere in the community so you're
segregating out particular individuals
and this is what really kind of had the
hairs on the back of my neck going up
those rules and reg ation we would be
directed at and there's some other
things requiring remedial action only if
issues remain voluntarily uncorrected so
you're going to have individuals Within
These districts who are going to you're
going to have the ability to require
some kind of remedial action on somebody
who probably wasn't even in favor at
this begin with and this is the really
lovely one imposing fines for
non-compliance I don't think in these
districts should be
have given the ability to impose fines
and also of course it's going to be a
tax taxes involved so the 51% let's just
say if it's only 51% who vote for this
um those those 51% are going to be
forcing the other 49% to pay taxes for
these districts that they may not want
so for for those reasons and quite a few
more um I just don't think this is the
way to go I understand the the water
quality issues like I say I spend time
on a lake in Maine and I get it but I I
think this is just one step too far
thank you further questions
representative Elbert thank you Mr
chairman uh just a comment about your
concern about
51% imposing their will on 49% we've had
numerous votes this year uh
where uh bills were passed by a single
vote and we see that as an appropriate
way to legislate in the state so um
while I hear your concern I also say
recognize that this is how we work here
thank you for your comments
representative yella thank you uh Mr
chair um one of my main concerns with
this is Jerry mandering because the
people putting forward this proposed
area can choose the lots that they want
to be included and don't want to be
included and so you can easily
pull the residents and see if they're in
favor of it and see if they're not and
be able to find the ones that are and
include them and make sure to include
not enough of those people that oppose
it and so they can gerrymander this
thing however they like and there's no
rules against that and so I say that if
you're opposed to Jerry mandering then
you should be opposed to this Bill thank
you Mr chair thank you further comments
questions ju okay we'll have the clerk
call a rooll just um so everybody knows
representative y Kella you did walk in
after the motion was made so you won't
be able to actually cast a vote
but okay uh 1250 ought to pass yes Vice
chairman of power yes representative
Guthrie yes clerk votes yes
representative
lales oh he stepped out sorry uh
Kelly
no Representative aood
no representative Brown
no representative kill
no representative stavis
yes representative Tetro yes
representative elberger
yes represent Maori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frank yes and Mr chairman uh no uh
motion passes 12
to5 okay 12 to 5 I assume that will not
go on on the consent calendar uh
committee report representa stavis okay
and for our
side represent minority for the minority
yeah oh sorry for the minority uh
representative kahill thank
you okay with that we'll close the exact
session on H be
1250 and once the clerk is ready we'll
go to the next one
okay uh next up HB 1302 relative to
elective conservation Commissions in
towns open up the exact session on that
and I believe representative power has
an amendment thank you Mr chairman I
would like to offer to the committee um
Amendment
05h thank you do we have a
second i' like to second that Mr
representative Brown second
representative uh
power thank you Mr chairman
um as a result of our hearing and
feedback um that was given during the
hearing for this bill the amendment
simply eliminates the um sentence that
the selectman May remove an elected
member for cause after a public hearing
that didn't seem to make sense because
the um purpose of the bill was to have
the Conservation Commission members be
elected by the voters so that um
sentence was removed and the bill as
introduced thank you do we have any
discussion on the
amendment seeing none last the clerk to
call a
rooll okay adopt Amendment 2024
505 Vice chairman power yes represent
guthe yes clerk votes yes representative
lales yes representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes representative
awood yes representative Brown yes
representative kill yes representative
stavis yes representative Tetro yes
representative elberger yes
representative maory yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack yes and Mr chairman
yes uh motion passes 19 to
zero thank you Mr clerk representative
power do you have another motion yes
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass as amended on House Bill
1302 do we have a second I'd like to
second that Mr Mr chairman
representative Brown seconds it
representative power thank you Mr
chairman current law requires that
Conservation Commission members be
appointed um by the select board this
bill is enabling legislation which
allows Conservation Commission members
to be elected by the
voters
um it's similar to um current enabling
statute that allows voters to be able to
elect members of the planning board in
Zoning Board of adjustment and it's
notable that if this enabling
legislation were to be adopted by a a
town that they may also resend this if
they find that they don't like it or
it's not working out for them and the
once rescinded that the they could go
back to having the Selectmen appoint the
members and the last thing that I would
say is that conservation
commissions uh are playing an
increasingly important role in um towns
to protect and preserve our natural
resources and um watersheds and this
bill provides towns with the option to
be able to elect members to the
Conservation Commission and I would ask
that the committee support this bill as
amended thank
you are there any other represent
Holland so so when this came forward to
us the the um the big issue was that
there was a volunteer or someone who
applied for the Conservation Commission
he was a volunteer he had on paper at
least really great
credentials and uh I mean the
Conservation Commission is a you don't
even get a hundred bucks it's a it's a
volunteer uh position and it's also kind
of an entryway for a lot of people that
want to get into town government um it
lets you get involved it's really great
to work on your conservation lands but
this person felt like because of his
views the governing body would not kind
of black balled him would not allow him
to be uh be on the Conservation
Commission and I and so I understand why
he would want or why the ability to
elect officials would come up the thing
is I just don't think it would work so
in essence when the community said if
you have I've never actually seen
somebody apply for a voluntary
commission uh or Committee in town and
not be be uh brought on board it's a
volunteer position so I think when your
community that has this happened this
speaks to a deeper problem that you're
having occurring there's clearly a rift
occurring between your governing body
and your community and so while you the
community could say yes we want to have
our Conservation Commission people
elected and put them on but really what
you probably are looking at is you want
to change your governing body at the
election you would say you know what the
governing body is no longer
representative of our community they're
not allowing good people to come onto
our boards and so we don't think they're
best serving our community and so
therefore we're going to change who
represents us I just think if you if you
try to do an endr run around your
governing body and elect your um
Conservation Commission and have them
sitting with your governing body that
doesn't want them it just won't work and
so I think the real recourse is really
to change your governing body and so I I
I just don't think this would work so
that's that's my two cents
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
so I I I will be supporting this
legislation because I I've seen in my
own town where people volunteered for
similar boards and we shot down just for
personal reasons because of the board
and and we we all got elected to office
and people should have the opportunity
if they're getting shut down because
their hair is blue or or for whatever
reason it it is that they're getting
shut down I mean there's millions of
reasons why someone might make
a a uh I don't know what the word I'm
looking for is yeah so I I think this in
would put fairness back in the
opportunity to participate and I think
we should allow for elections this
country is founded on
elections thank you represent kahill
represent stavis thank you Mr chair I I
cannot support this bill I did support
the amendment because I think it makes
the underlying Bill a better Bill uh but
I can't support the bill because for a
number of reasons having been on this
commit me for six years now I have seen
so many of this similar kind of Bill
come before us where an
individual it's not working for him or
her and so they seek this committee to
to pass legislation that will make it
work for him or her and that's not what
we do here um we are about the
municipalities and the counties and not
about individuals that may be having
issues with the
municipalities uh I also feel that it's
not good policy to have members of a
body that is advisory only in elected
positions um it it kind of warps the
balance of power and sets up unrealistic
expectations for the people who are in
those positions that are advisory only
um that the PE people who elect them may
think that they should have more power
than they do but in point of fact they
don't and so I think it's not fair to
them and I don't think it's fair to the
people who would elect them if this bill
were to become law and if it were
adopted by a municipality thank you Mr
chair for the comments representative
Gallagher um so uh I'd agree with
representative sais about being
skeptical about um the particular
motivating case for this
legislation but uh personally I think we
need to look Beyond just that one case
and towards the broader principles
involved of democracy and um you know I
think that the more positions that can
be elected positions rather than
appointed positions uh the better like
you know that's something I've
um you know that that that's something
that I've programmed to social media
about to just constantly come up with
new ideas for positions that should be
elected rather than appointed um so yeah
just based on the principle of uh
supporting democracy I'm going to
support this
belill representative
major thank you Mr chairman um uh as
with my friend from Lebanon I I
supported the amendment because I think
it does make the bill better but I
cannot support the bill conservation
commissions um have a very specific role
to be stewards of the land they are part
of I mean they have that bias they have
that
responsibility uh that shouldn't be uh
that shouldn't fall to uh having to be
elected they need people to and I and I
understand what happened in that
Community was probably wrong but the the
statute for conservation commissions has
been in existence since before I was
born and I'm and I'm old and
so and
uh and this is the this is the first
time you know I'm hearing about this uh
I I I work very very closely with the
Conservation Commission in my town as a
member of the select board and the and
ax officio of the planning board we work
very very closely together they have an
enormous responsibility uh and an
enormous task which I think is very
specific uh and and requires a skill set
and I would hope in that Community uh
that this problem could be rectified but
I haven't heard of this problem in any
other community I I recommend uh I
recommend that we uh reject the OTP uh
and and then go to itl on the bill thank
you Mr
chairman representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will also be
opposing this for the reasons that have
been stated by uh representative stavis
and other members of this committee um I
have worked with numerous conservation
commissions and I feel very strongly
that our environment in New Hampshire is
very important and the conservation
conservation commissions as has been
noted are advisory and they seek out
people who have a dear deep interest and
love for the conservation areas our
forests our Weds and you don't find that
when you politicize this position so I
will be uh voting against this thank
you represent power thank you Mr
chairman I am deeply disappointed that
people on this committee are making this
about one particular case that is not
the point and I find that very
disappointing um I would also like to
point out that any position that that is
either appointed or elected
it it's volunteer it's not a requirement
that anybody runs for any office or
volunteers to be appointed to any
position it's all
volunteer
um the other thing that I would say is
we also have a bill House Bill 1124 that
that speaks to concerns with regards to
the concentration of power um by a
select board
and again I will repeat that this is
enabling legislation it's not a mandate
if a if a municipal a town wants to
adopt this they can I I I I feel that
people are missing the point in
that instead of having a a select few a
handful of Selectmen
appointing people to a Conservation
Commission why not let the voters choose
who they want
and you know additionally this whole
notion that you're going to get better
um people appointed to the board if it's
if it's appointed versus elected well
again you know if you're not
interested or passionate or you know
about conservation you you're either way
whether it's appointed or elected you're
not going to raise your hand
so that that's my followup to the
comments thank you Mr chairman
representative
Elward so I can attest to a
town that engages in
nepotism
favoritism
cronyism and a lot of other
isms
so they will arbitrarily form
committees they won't solicit for um
letters of Interest
and this is a huge problem in this town
so it does exist I hear it from lots of
other
towns and I think
that
electing these
individuals by the voters is going to be
more
fair uh to everybody thank you
representative
lales thank you Mr chairman um as we
have progressed I I find myself um
agreeing with all my
colleagues and it's it's uh uh somewhat
uh um disconcerting when I agree with
everybody when everybody's on different
sides of the fence I find myself
straddling that fence but as we go
forward here in New Hampshire we're a a
state with many small towns
and power within a community can be
concentrated in one group of people and
some of those people could be related or
whatever uh so in my mind I I agree with
my colleague representative Gallagher
that electing members of the
Conservation Commission seems to me a a
much fairer way of getting input into
this increasingly important commission I
think that the thing that that uh puts
me on the side of this bill is the fact
that it is enabling so a town can get
into it or they can back
out uh they can stick their toes in the
water whatever so I will be uh I will be
supporting the OTP thank you
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman um so this is a reason why we
have these discussions so I agree with
um representative lalis I came in with a
different thought but you have changed
my mind so I'll be supporting this
represent kill thank you for letting me
speak again Mr chair I I would like to
Echo our good colleague over here is
that I agree with a lot of the points
you guys have made some really really
good points but this literally is just
as the board this board in particular is
an Advisory Board this is an enabling
piece of legislation and we do have NEP
problems in this state I mean my town is
um notorious for this sort of thing um
and and I'd like to see that change I'd
like to see more people participate and
get an opportunity to use their voice um
so I while you guys have all made really
great points I do think that we should
support this
legislation
FR thank you Mr chair um I walked into
this room this morning on the fence not
really knowing
which way I should go on it listening to
the debate um I'm tending to agree with
representative lales and others who are
going to support the bill I guess my
bottom line is I view this as a bill
that can do no harm because it is
enabling a town can vote to elect their
Conservation Commission a town can vote
to unelect and go back to appointed so I
think giving various towns which may
have problems with concentration of
power the ability to change that is a
good idea thank
you representative
stavis thank you Mr chair well they say
that people who can't change their minds
never change
anything and um I have been convinced by
the arguments of my colleagues that this
is enabling legislation it can do no
harm it could do some good in certain
towns
[Music]
um I remain concerned about the original
impetus for the bill but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a bad idea um
so I will be supporting this legislation
as amended
thank
you no okay no I'm just
gonna just going to
W that's why I was looking at you that
way I know I know I got that
disapproving all right seeing no further
comments we'll ask the clerk to callar
roll on HB 1302 as
amended okay ought to pass on through
1802 Vice chairman
power I ought to pass as amended as
amended I'm sorry thank you I vote Yes
ought to pass as amended representative
Guthrie yes clerk votes yes
representative lales yes representative
Ella yes representative Kelly yes
representative awood yes representative
Brown
yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
T yes representative alberger yes
Representative majori
no representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Holland
no representative priest
no uh representative Frank
yes Mr chairman
yes motion passes
16-3 16-3 is there
opposition of it going on to
consent I I'm I'm okay with that but we
would write a report I see no opposition
to the to the consent all right um on
the report uh representative power will
write it for the otpa
and repres of howand will write
the opposition report or whatever they
yep okay very good that closes the
hearing on HB
1302 the executive session
sorry e
okay we go ahead and open up the
executive session HB 1359 relative to
the appeals of certain zoning Decisions
by Butters I understand representative
power you have an amendment thank you Mr
chairman I would like to offer to this
committee Amendment
section one and section two of the bill
as introduced and that provision is to
allow for a property owner within the M
municipality to be able to appeal and
the reason why I feel that this is
important is
um while I while I do agree that the
statute as it is right now is is very
broad um I feel that the bill is
introduced is too narrow and while a a a
property owner within the municipality
might not be in a butter per the
definition of a butter contained within
this
bill there are instances where um a
property owner can be affected by a a
decision by the local land use board for
example with when you have the ma
majority of our um houses in the state
of New Hampshire are on private Wells so
an example would be where you would have
within a town a development that goes in
and you have an established neighborhood
and that those neighborhoods have that
the people in that neighborhood have
private Wells and they're all drawing
off of an aquafer that's shared now
while certain homes might not be Butters
by a by definition they are they would
be affected by say a street going in
with you know 15 20 what whatever our
house is and I had contacted the dees
with regards to um well permitting and
rules and regulations and their
involvement is only to the degree with
regards to the sighting of
wells and the thing to consider is that
when um you know Wells are tested that
is in
isolation it's very different when all
the houses in uh development be come
online and they're all drawing water for
different uses through throughout
throughout the day so I I feel very
strongly that um like I said the bill is
introduced goes uh you know is too
restrictive and this is a a happy medium
to open up a bit more to address any
concerns um by Property Owners within
the municipality and I would also add
that with with regard to any development
that goes on it can in fact affect the
municipal Services the schools traffic
Etc and that does affect people in the
town in the area who may not be a
Butters thank you Mr chair
chairman repres representative Brown
could you turn off your mic
representative
Elward thank you Mr
chairman I am so happy to see this and I
think it should run across all boards
making um quasi
judicial decisions a prime
example uh would be an excavation
project obviously with the negative
noise impacts and other typ types of
impacts you you you could be thousands
of feet away and not in a
butter and I believe that this is vital
in fact I had worked
on something similar because of the
problem of um the excavation situation
so bravo bravo thank you for the
comments representative uh uh
praise thank you Mr uh uh Mr chairman um
I will be opposing this uh Amendment
because I think it's counterproductive
to the intent of the bill and the bill
was to really limit the property owners
that are going to be affected by this
zoning decision so this opens it up to
anyone in the
town um to come up with a Friv
objection that could be made to stop a
project and it has happened and will
continue to happen with this amendment
thank you representative
yella thank you um I have I think that
this is just uh this amendment or the
the addition of any property owner in
the municipality is just um even as
stated by the people in support of it is
for uh nimbyism that does not want that
is not directly
uh or is not impacted the same way that
uh a butter would be and these anyone
that is concerned and impacted has the
right already to go to the municipality
or to go to the hearing and be heard
they have a right to that already in the
current
law um and this is just about appealing
and this does not just limit to the
people that are actually affected in the
in the current law it says a person
directly affected this is saying no no
we're scrapping that we're going to do
even people that aren't
affected congratulations now you can
appeal also I think that's actually take
trying to take one step forward and two
steps back and so so for that reason I
think that this is uh should not be
adopted thank you representative
Gallagher um I'd like to Echo uh the
comments by Representatives PRI and
Yokel um I think it's important to
consider this legislation in the context
of our larger um housing crisis in the
state where uh one of the main drivers
of that is um nimbyism and Neighbors
being able to say no to developments
when we really do need to be doing
developments um so yeah I I think this
um amendment is kind of going in the
opposite direction of the um that the
bill was originally supposed to do um so
I'll be opposing
it anybody who hasn't spoken yet I'll
get to one second representative Elward
um I'm going to make a comment kind of
based on what um
representative
yiset and as written technically this
actually is almost the amendment's
almost worse than the original and
here's the
reason um looking at it it opens it up
to any individual in the municipality
now I when I introduced this bill
originally I said you know I live on the
Southeast side of
barington on the other side of North
west side of barington close to 10 miles
away this would give that
individual for no reason and as
representative yella pointed out it
originally said any person aggrieved now
we that that applied to anybody that
could be anybody worldwide and the whole
intent of this was to wrap it in now if
the intent here was any AG grieved
property owner in the municipality that
might
be okay I still would not support it but
this opens it up to any property owner
in the municipality without a reason so
for that for that reason I willon I
can't support um the amendment uh
representative Elward go ahead thank you
Mr
chairman making an appeal to the Zoning
Board of
adjustment is is not not like attending
a public hearing and standing up and
voicing your
opinion you have to
prepare your reasoning based on fact and
law it usually takes like an
attorney to do a successful
appeal so this is not something that I
think would be
undertaken lightly
by in a frivolous way
now I know of a town
currently where the planning board chair
actually attempted to insert the
planning board as a
party to the subdivision applicants
appeal to the
zba based on any person agree
grieved it is currently the case has
currently um going before the land use
board uh on
appeal
so um I I think
that this is necessary to help protect
the interest of anybody in the
municipality and I support this
repr major thank you Mr chairman um I
will not be supporting the amendment I I
absolutely support your bill and um for
all the reasons that I've heard here and
I'm and I'm thinking the only thing I
will add is one of the submitted
questions for our candidate tonight asks
uh candidates for the planning board who
has the largest voice uh or who who
should be who should have the voice in
an application is it the abutter the
applicant the zoning administrator uh
the board who should have this voice and
we're all looking for that equality the
answer is we're all looking to have an
equal voice I'm not sure that I would
want as you say Mr chairman somebody who
is not even close to this property who
may not be affected in any way shape or
form to have that equal voice in this
conversation I think it should be as it
was originally drafted the abutter as
defined in statute so I cannot support
the amendment but we'll be supporting
the Bill thank you representative kahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
letting me address the board um so I'm
going to describe a scenario
where a project was put in that was
detrimental not just to to my property
but everyone down river for me um where
I could not um voice my opinion because
I was not an a butter by about 15
ft and there was a a a project in
Raymond that was on a piece of land that
is a brown field where they they took
out some dams and flowed potentially
chemical poisoned water across my
property into a river that affects 17
municipalities down river for me but
because there was a piece of land in
between me that's about 15 ft long and
them I wasn't even giving in a butter
notice you know so I think there are
some problems where I'm I'm not 10 miles
away I'm 15 ft away and I didn't have a
voice in in that um project and and not
only that that when they did do the
blasting for that project they broke all
the windows in my
house so there are there are potential
problems where you could be 10 miles
away on the same ledge as a project
going on and it can do damage to your
foundation and your a house and I've
seen it
firsthand representative
stavis thank you Mr chair this is really
a fascinating conversation I want to
thank my colleagues for for really
delving into this issue I I always say
that the housing crisis that afflicts
New
Hampshire is an 850 piece jigsaw puzzle
and that every time we consider a piece
of legislation we are looking at tiny
tiny little piece of a larger picture
and I think that this
bill in its original form as it came to
us as
introduced solves one piece of that 850
piece jigsaw puzzle it doesn't work for
everyone but it really
helps the cause for people who want to
build housing for
example um for the reasons that my
colleague representative award stated so
correctly an appeal to a land use board
is not to be taken lightly it's
something that is expensive timec
consuming way more expensive than anyone
ever expected it to be and it kills
projects in their infancies
and it's simply in my view not fair that
these projects should be appealed to
death before they can even get a public
hearing and so I can't support the
amendment but I do support the
underlying Bill thank
you thank you uh representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman I come
from the city of nashwa which I just
checked to make sure I had the numbers
right it includes 31.7 square miles it's
a big city uh I live in one end of it
not in the middle and
given
this uh Amendment if I had an objection
to something that was happening all the
way across town that really had no
impact on me it would be okay for me to
go and say I don't want it let's stop
it on the other
side as a resident and looking at the
original language of any person AG
grieved some of you may know that there
was a uh petition to put in an asphalt
plant in one of the most densely
populated areas of the city and while
the initial objections and push back
came from people within that
neighborhood and the plant by the way
was going to be half a mile away from an
elementary
school uh the entire city got involved
in opposing it and looking at the
language of any person AG grieved we
still would be able to do that so I see
that the change in language is
unnecessary and we'll be voting against
it thank you represent power did you
have your
hand thank you Mr chairman um I'd like
to point out two things that any person
AG grieved in the bill as introduced was
struck by the um Prime sponsor in when
this bill was filed and the second thing
that I would like to note is it is my
understanding that with regards to
making an appeal there is a 30-day time
period in which that appeal must be
filed and then 30 days in which that
appeal must be heard locally that 60
days I don't see that as a big um time
killer for any project so I just wanted
to share
that representative gagar
um so one thing that was mentioned
previously that I'd kind of like to push
back on um so it says um said that um
this open Amendment opens it up to
anyone in the community and um i' just
like to refer back to the bill language
it says a property owner in the
municipality and I that I think that's
kind of um representative of a bad habit
that
um sometimes this committee can get in
which is is only thinking of property
owners as people when really it's the
people who
aren't
um what it it's the people who don't own
property who need are generally the ones
who need housing um so if I if I were
going
to if I wanted to open up the language
to more people in the community I would
specifically say it should be the
non-property owners in the
municipality who should
um who it should be changed to but um
that's not what it says it just says
Property Owners so um yeah I I think
that's a bad aspect of the amendment and
reason to oppose
it forther comments representative did
you have one representative y Kell yeah
I just back with you
represent um I did want
to I mean I I do kind of agree with
representative Gallagher that um
Property Owners is um it could could be
anyone
uh within that area that that is even
not a property owner
um and so but uh there was a previous
discussion about um
testimony uh not being not being allowed
for people that are can demonst that
their land will be directly affected and
that's um stated on page two line 16 to
17 um that they should have the same
rights as a butter in that that
hearing um and I think
that that is I I forgot the other other
uh thing that I was going to say so I
think representative Hicks
representative Gallagher could you turn
off your mic please thank you thank you
yes
uh I'm thinking about this in property
um where my um my school is I'm thinking
about water pollution uh thinking about
the aquifer where we draw the water um
for the school thinking about air
pollution potentially and noise
pollution and not being in a direct
butter um concerns me and I think that I
I appreciate representative power for
bringing that issue to light I I
originally liked the uh
initial bill because of nism um but now
I don't like either enough to support
either uh so I kind of wish that we
could make another motion um and fix
this in a way that supports everybody's
I'm going to take a point of personal
privilege here and that is I I'm getting
the feeling that the amendment may not
work I'm getting a feeling that the
underlying bill May there will be other
opportunities for this to be amended
when it goes over to the other body I
will just leave it at that
maybe representative
priest uh thank you Mr chairman um I
again would just like to emphasize the
fact that when you are proposing a
development time is money and if and
there are people in our communities
that will do everything in their power
to oppose and to delay a project or to
kill a project if it's in competition
with it if they don't like it or it's
bringing in the wrong kind of people in
their Community they'll do everything
they can and so that's why I think it's
important to kind of focus on who is
really being affected and that is
defined in the original bill and I think
we should just go ahead and and vote
down this amendment and and and focus on
the the bill itself thank
you seeing no more hit
oh see no more hands uh McDonald could
you call a rooll on the
amendment HB 1359 Amendment 202
40778 H Vice chairman power yes
representative Guth no clerk votes yes
Representative
silus
no uh representative Keller no
representative Kelly
no representative Harwood
yes representative Brown representative
kahill yes
Representative stavis
no representative Tetro
no Representative elberger
no Representative majori no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks
no representative Howland no
representative Priest
No representative Frank
no Mr chairman
no uh motion fails uh 17 to leave
two say that number again uh no 17
to 16 to3 that sounds
better okay the the amendment fails so
now we are back on the original will HB
1359 do I have a motion on that Mr
chairman representative priest I make a
motion to uh ought to pass
on uh HB
1359 thank you representative y Kell
seconds uh down the end of the could you
guys turn your mics off again
representative Kelly
please Mike
turn your mic thank
you further discussion on the underlying
Bill representative hit so thank you Mr
chairman I will be supporting the bill
but I do have um concerns that
representative power raised with the
previous um amendment that she
filed thank you further comments
represent power thank you Mr chairman I
will not be supporting the motion of
ought to pass there's there's concerns
in isues with this bill as written and I
agree with um representative Hicks his
previous comments from before and I feel
that this these issues that I've raised
does in fact need to be addressed and
this bill as written is
insufficient further
comments seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the world
sure
excuse yes representative lales if I may
um we've had a very interesting
discussion about this particular Bill
and it seems to me that there's a lot of
good
thoughts uh
perhaps there we could uh rather than
passing a bill that we're hoping that
eventually will be
amended perhaps we could retain it in
the committee and do some more work on
it so that when we submit the bill to
the house that we have something that we
can be proud of
uh I'm I'm thinking interim study or
something like
that from the Chairman's perspective no
first of all we can't do I mean we could
do uh interim study but that's basically
killing it all together so we don't I'm
not going to go with that I think since
we're already the motions have already
been made I think we need to take the
vote on it if we were to get a vote
something like that we also will have
the ability on the house floor for
anybody who wants to debate it I would
also say that
I the previous vote we took on the
amendment I think if it had been written
slightly different it might
have maybe had a little more support um
we've already discussed that I've made
my points on that so I'm not going to
say it again but again we do have the
opportunity there's ability for floor
amendments there's ability in the Senate
I mean there's all kinds of other ways
but I would prefer that we move forward
on this
one so when the clerk is ready
okay uh ought to pass HP
1359 Vice chairman power
no repr
three clerk votes no representative
sales
no representative Kella
yes representative
Kelly oh goodness um no
representative Alward
no Representative kahill
no representative
stavis
yes representative
Tetro
no representative
elberger
yes representative maery
yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
yes representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack
yes Mr chairman
yes motion passes 10 to uh
8 108 108 sorry okay so this will not go
on the consent calendar uh the chairman
will write the committee report for the
OTP who would like to write the
committee report
for against the OTP anybody
representative
power okay repres Power
y okay that closes the executive session
on HB
1359 all right uh we'll give the
chairman uh the clerk just a minute and
then we'll move on to the next one
these gaps in time where where our
friend representative lales would
normally regil us with some presidential
or election history
anything um no he does he does not at
this
time Mr clerk you all set okay uh open
up the uh executive session on HB
1478 uh prohibiting a person from
membership on the school board and
select board concurrently do we have a
motion representative Brown yes Mr
chairman thank you I'd like to make the
uh motion to itl the bill is poorly
written up up we need a first we have a
second representative Kelly second now
representative Brown I'm always too
anxious so the bill is poorly written
the prime didn't show when we uh uh had
the hearing on it and the content of the
bill is supposedly rolled into house
bill
1124 further comments scene
representative
Guthrie I just like
to personal
comments uh I always felt that any offic
that you could run for you and get
elected you you were able to do that and
then take that right away that uh you
could not serve on any board because you
weren't allowed to run for it that's
offensive to me to begin with and the
second question uh comment I have is we
had in my town a a fellow who had the
time to do both selectman and school
committee and I think that's the key I
know a lot of was here on uh on the
committee of both the Selman and the
State Rep uh that's T kind of time
consuming for both jobs but uh those of
us who are are doing both feel that we
can uh can can do do the both jobs so I
just thought I'd make that as as a
comment I don't think you should uh uh
demand that anybody can cannot run for
an office and I think these two offices
uh it's to some advantages if somebody
has the time to do both jobs thank you
Mr chair thank you further
comments seeing representative Gallagher
um so yeah I'd just like to um point out
that uh no one showed up at the hearing
for it so we had to do basically one of
those proforma introductions for it um
so um I mean I might be open to the idea
if someone had bothered to explain why
it's a good idea or is necessary but
since they didn't um then yeah I'm just
going to be joining the vote
against okay seeing no more comments
we'll ask the clerk to call a roll on
the itl motion for
HB uh 1478 yes sir okay our vice
chairman power
yes representative Guthrie yes clerk
votes yes representative
lales yes representative
yella
yes representative Kelly yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro yes representative elberger
yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative howand yes representative
priest yes representative Frank yes and
Mr chairman yes motion passes itl 19 to
Zer very good representative Brown will
you be writing the committee report on
this one yes Mr chair chairman thank you
thank
you and without objection it will go on
the consent calendar seeing no
objections we will go ahead and close
the exec session on HB
1478 and we will proceed to the next one
in just a minute or
two okay
yes
sir
1449 I think my
colleague French benefits are are
good oh never
all right uh next one up is HB 1449
relative to priting the board of lot tax
and land appeals from ordering
retroactive
appraisals and the rest of
it so uh do we have a motion on HB 1449
executive session
Mr Mr chairman I move
itl on House Bill 1449 thank you do we
have a second representative priest
seconds the motion of itl on HP
1449 and representative majority would
you like to speak uh thank you Mr
chairman I I uh I'm wondering if I can
defer to the Prime on this for reasons
why uh itl is the best option may I of
course you may representative hick thank
you Mr chairman and colleague majori um
I appreciate everybody's comment on this
uh I think it is well intentioned and I
don't think it's ready to be passed I
think there's more work to be done um
with the btla and my constituent um to
come up with some sort of resolution so
I won't support the it but I understand
if everybody else does and I won't
object to consent
well said representative further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call a
rooll okay HB 1449 itl Vice chairman
power yes representative Guthrie collect
votes yes representative salus yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly yes representative aood yes
representative Brown yes represent
kahill yes representative stavis
yes representative Tetro yes
representative alberger yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks
no representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frank yes and Mr chairman yes motion
passes 18 to one thank you Mr clerk uh
without objections on to the consent
calendar I see no objections and
committee report will be written by
representative
Hicks that closes the executive session
on HB
1449 and we will get to the next one in
just a second representative power point
point of inquiry Mr chairman so um if
I'm not mistaken representative Hicks
voted against the motion of itl so why
would he be writing the majority report
for
that I think it doesn't really matter um
but if you would like to write it in
somebody else's name I'm happy to write
it and hand it to miss uh represent
majori that's fine okay represent
majori I approve I Hicks you do not I
mean you can it there's nothing that
says you can't I'm happy to write if
it's proper I'm happy to write it why
don't you I think that's fine I will
yeah exactly
very good uh next a h b 1120 exec
session repealing the provision that
requires the reflection of a municipal
body vote on warrant
articles uh let's see do we have a
motion on that representative Brown yes
Mr chairman I have a motion to itl this
bill do we have a second representative
power would you like to speak to your
motion see how good I was that time yes
Mr chairman um having uh recently uh
been to a school board meeting in my
town of Molen bro um there was a lot of
discussion about uh some issues that had
come up and during the meeting uh a lot
of the attendees had asked what the ABC
committee had said on it what the CIP
committee had said cipc committee and
what the uh school board members had
voted on and a lot of the people were um
encouraged to ask questions as a result
of what what the indication of the votes
were 4:1 5:1 whatever it was and they
asked why some people had voted for and
why some people had voted against so my
opinion on this is that this allows
people
to um to ask questions of their elected
officials that they may not otherwise
ask and if it wasn't allowed it would
deprive these people of that information
uh allowing them to uh to request
additional information that's the reason
why I uh feel that we should itl this
Bill thank you further
comments representative yela I just
wanted to correct a statement that
representative Brown just said I think
that this this bill does not actually
forbid them from putting it on there it
just removes the requirement that they
put it on there um and so they can
choose to or can not choose to and so I
think that the entire thrust of this
bill was to make it so that they can't
put it on there and so I think the bill
just doesn't do what it was intended to
do by the sponsor and so um I think that
he should go back to the drawing board
and and put a bill forward that actually
does what he wants it to do before we
should even consider passing it so for
that reason I'm going to uh uh vote to
itl this bill
thanks representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting against this bill because I think
we have elected elected boards advisory
boards and I'm going when I'm going into
The Ballot Box to vote on a particular
item and we all know that we're all very
busy and we're all not up to speed with
what's going on with every warrant it's
always great to know how the various
boards voted and this would be taking
away that
so thank
you represent kill thank you Mr chair um
because we had a lengthy discussion on
1302 with nepotism and things that that
that can happen in
town um and because I have seen on Town
election ballots on citizen sponsored
warrants where it says not recommended
by the select board and because the
sponsor of this bill did a really good
job showing us that in in fact could be
electioneering I will be supporting his
bill representative
Gallagher um so I like just like to say
um I'm not necessarily opposed to um
the principle of General principle of
the bill um I do think that
um yeah if the information is also
available in other ways then it's not
really that necessary to also have it on
the ballot but I don't think we have
really quite ensured that the
information is in fact available in
other ways yet um for example that live
streaming Bill um like I think we should
um
we that's currently an interim study um
if we do
eventually pass the um live streaming
Bill um then yeah I could be convinced
to come back and support a future
version of this legislation but until
that happens I don't think I can and um
one one additional point I'd make um is
that um
on uh corporate um
proxy statements when you own a stock in
a company and um can vote on things for
their General meaning they also print
how their board of directors will vote
so it would seem kind of weird to me to
prevent our towns from doing something
that um corporations can also do um so
yeah that that just seems kind of weird
to be giving corporations more power
power than governments in that respect
um so
yeah that's what I have to say
representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman I I know
that in the discussion of the board of
the bill there was uh the election heing
came up and uh I think that was one of
the main concerns but I suggest to you
there's nothing wrong with El election
heing in fact in my town we have a
voters
guide uh and I guess that's ele you know
election and we
have uh our
candidates uh standing out at the at the
polls and that's election heing so I
would say suggest that uh that I
wouldn't be concerned with that word and
that I would say that any information
for the
voter whatever it is is good information
and uh it it goes along with a lot of
other things of the if the voter is
concerned and and and is involved so my
suggestion is that we of course we don't
vote uh we vote the itl this bill and
don't encourage the uh uh the bill
writer to correct it and try to make it
so that uh you can't put that
information on the
bot representative
FR thank you Mr chairman um I think it's
important for the voters to get as much
information as they can from whatever
Source in regards to the concern that a
select
board
might recommend against a petitioned
warrant article which they have the
right to do the voters also have the
right to ask the select men or whatever
board has made that
recommendation why they made the
recommendation and the voters can then
decide for themselves whether the
recommendation for or
against is something that they agree
with or they don't agree with thank you
representative
lales yes in this case I I'm going to
rely on my personal experience and my
personal experience in our town is that
the the town's voters really rely on the
budget committee to be an
independent uh body that looks at things
maybe a little different than the
selectman or maybe a little different
than the school board but they have an
independent voice and and the voters
really rely on the budget
committee for guidance and so taking
that away I think would be a real
detriment to the education of the
voters representative major thank you Mr
chairman uh I want to Echo my friend
from Londoner just said I I know on the
ballot in Northampton uh we include the
the thoughts of the C IP committee which
is certainly a bipartisan committee uh
we include the budget committee which is
an official budget committee but acts
independently we have the impact we've
had uh the impact of the tax rate um on
there and of course we have the the the
opinion of the select board all of those
things have been approved by Dr and have
never been questioned in the 18 years
that I have sat on the select board once
we put out a a voter guide in the town
and we were nearly taken to court
they don't mind it on the ballot but we
we put out a voter guide just explaining
our position and we were almost taken to
court uh we've never done that again so
I I um I think the voters should have as
much information as as they need thank
you representa stavis uh sorry
representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman
um our town is considering a $3 million
Bond
for a
municipal safety
building and all I can say is after
attending the public hearings the
deliberative session uh requesting
records the budget committee does not
recommend the article the Selectmen do
and I believe that the voters are going
to rely because of the concent of power
in my town are going to really rely on
the budget committee's
recommendation so I I don't want to see
that taken
away now represent s thank you Mr chair
I just have a lot more faith in our
voters than I hear being voiced here um
if there are questions to be asked I
have faith that they will ask them if
there are decisions that they disagree
with with I have faith that they will
voice those disagreements and so I will
be supporting the itl on this Bill thank
you for the
comments seeing none
um representative lales me mentioned
straddling off fence on a previous bill
and I got I got to admit I find myself
going back and forth on this one I see
both sides of the argument uh it could
really go any way one of the issues that
I think many of us talk about all the
time is the lack of involvement by
citizens um and them not understanding
what really what's going on u in their
towns I I make the comment frequently I
could walk down the town of barington
and say hi to somebody and they wouldn't
probably know I'm even their
representative so I I I I talked with
the prime sponsor this morning about I
told him I actually love the concept of
what you're trying to do and because I
think we need more involvement and less
reliant on our citizens just going up
and going oh what they say what they say
but you can't lead a horse to water yeah
I mean you can lead the horse water you
can't make them drink so I go back and
forth
um I don't know what I'll
[Laughter]
do representative Elberta thank you Mr
chairman having spent a long time
working in
uh Mental Health Services one of the
things that I heard frequently was that
the only thing that you really get from
sitting on a fence is a sore
behind uh and I am sort of my behind
here is getting sorer and sorer the more
I'm I'm uh
listening when we are
voting we get in our
uh record the house record
statements about why people are
supporting and why they're not and then
we are free to choose how we want to
vote I don't see that that would be a
bad idea to have voters get this is why
we think it's a good idea this is why we
think it's a bad idea if the budget
committee believes this they can write
that if the select board believes this
they can write that but making sure that
there are here's why
for either side make your decision I
don't see it's a bad idea to say who
made that decision because if voters
keep seeing the same people offering
opinions that you disagree with then you
know to vote against them not just to
feel like you have to vote the way they
chose because they happen to be the
community leaders so as I said I have no
idea how I'm going to vote on
this you're a member of the fence Club
yeah yes representative
yella so I I actually like the
suggestion uh just given about
essentially a voter's guide or whatever
like I I'm often the person voting no on
on budget committee things and I
generally don't
speak uh at the budget committee about
why because I'm just wasting everyone's
time because there's I'm the only one
voting no and so I wouldn't um waste
everyone's time with that but I might
put in uh a Minority Report or something
in some voters guide about why this is
not a great idea and those interested
might be able to do that now do I think
as the previous representative said that
I should be able to go inside the the
polling place and be able to electioneer
inside the polling place no I don't
think that's the proper place for it to
be so maybe if we have some uh uh so
maybe there is some option as far as
like putting that in statute and saying
that it it could be available at the
town hall or something like that whereas
not inside of the polling place um I
might be in favor of that but regard
going back to representative stav's
thing I trust the the voters to research
and ask questions um and so for that
reason I'm going to change and vote Yes
that they can go and ask those questions
outside of the polling booth and not
inside of the polling booth and so uh
you've convinced me to vote Yes uh or
ought to pass AKA uh the way that I
previously current motion is itl right
oppos the I was previously for now I'm
going to bees supporting thank you Mr
chairman very briefly um when this was
presented uh I was thinking just
definitions and I was thinking okay so
if I want to vote for representative
Gallagher when I go into the voting
booth and I have his platform listed for
me uh electioneering and I don't see I
think the bias of when we have votes we
had votes in front of us we go in the
voting booth I think that's election are
so I'll be voting against the
itl representative power thank you Mr
chairman um I would like to also point
out
that in New Hampshire we have SP2 towns
and traditional Town
meetings and if I'm not mistaken
majority of towns are traditional Town
meetings and there are
no voting booths the this information is
printed on the warrant and the warrant
articles are voted on at the town
meeting so um I think we're losing focus
here with regards to this bill and
um just in general the ability to
provide a notation um with regards to
Warrant
articles that's important um in my
opinion to be able to um provide
information from these boards that the
you know the residents are looking for
that information from the people that
they elected and um to remove that would
be depriving the voters of information
thank
youwood thank you Mr chairman in my town
we have approximately 800 registered
voters at the deliberative session
where2 town uh
approximately 3540 people showed up um
and we do publish an annual report that
could be a place where information could
be contained and legal
perhaps there are members Mr
chairman continue representative Elward
then we'll go to representative power
okay thank you so anyway um at Max I
have seen approximately 350 voters show
up that's it so I can guarantee you
people are not reaching out for
information repres Mr chairman I I
apologize for interrupting but I was
being informed that there are members of
the committee who are carrying on
conversations while another member is
speaking and I just it was a reaction
for me to try to signal to those members
please stop talking thank you very much
for that members who were talking please
stop representative
stavis I I think there's sufficient
questions about what's in this bill and
what the implications might be that it's
just not ready for prime
time um again I'm going to say that I
support the
itl I just think the bill is vague and I
think that the notion behind it
is
assumed and may or may not be true and I
just think it's just not ready I agree
that it's an important issue and perhaps
one that warrants further study
but not
today seeing no more comments
represented uh Mr clerk would you call
the role on the motion of itl on HB
1120 thank you Mr chairman Vice chairman
power yes representative Guthrie yes
clier votes yes representative Salis yes
Representative
ellaa
no representative Kelly
yes representative aood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
no representative
stavis yes representative
Tetro
yes representative elberger
yes representative maor
yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks
no representative Howland
yes representative priest
yes representa Frank yes Mr
chairman
no uh motion passes 15 to
4 okay uh motion of itl was made by
representative Brown so representative
Brown you will be writing
the committee report for the motion of
itl is there any objection
well does anybody want to put this
on other than the consent calendar
regular
calendar if there's an objection there
is for against normally if it's three or
above usually it goes on the regular
calendar
who's going to write all right let me
ask this first who's going to write the
uh report against representative
yala if you want me to I will if if
representative yella can get it to me
promptly yes I would love you to sure I
will write it very good so why don't we
um is there I'll is there an objection
to it going on to the consent calendar
hearing none it will go on the consent
calendar
there what's that so you don't need me
to then oh yeah we still want to still
want to report as to why you can object
to it going on the consent and it will
it won't I
mean I don't believe I think that you
need to check with the clerk but I don't
believe
uh things on the consent calendar have
minority
reports otherwise they would be on
absolutely they always do
oh yeah on the consent calendar oh yeah
I've never seen that okay it's fine we
always do I know that
yeah so do you want are you objecting to
the consent sure let's go ahead and
object and then I'll write the committee
report and make this super simple all
right
awesome glad we got past that all right
that closes exact on HB 11120
okay we already talked about 1124 that
one is still under the microscopes as is
1180 so when the clerk is ready and it
appears he is we're going to open up the
executive hearing on
hb125 and I believe
representative stavis you have a amend
motion on an am thank you Mr chair I'd
like to to offer uh Amendment 2024
d784 um um this is an amendment that's
sub do we have a second the amendment
represent representative T
seconds representative stavis sorry Mr
chair thank you got carried away there
um this is an amendment that um really
shortens this bill to its and and kind
of boils it down to its Essence um I
worked really hard with the sponsor to
uh to understand exactly what the goal
of the very long bill that uh she
originally presented to us was and the
the goal is simply to include County
Commission and delegation meetings in
the 91a require requirements for public
comment including public comment so this
is a very simple bill right now it just
adds a a new section to
91a that states that members residents
of the
County May participate in public meeting
in meetings of the County Commission or
delegation and they will have at least
three minutes to speak in a s session
designated by the chair of the
commission or the delegation thank you
Mr chair thank
you is there any discussion on this Bill
representative
Brown thank
you uh seeing none I will I'll make the
comment uh I'm totally in support there
were some minor changes that uh
representative stavis made and uh fully
support
it so see no more further comments
representative um or Mr clerk I always
say that uh could you call the role on
the amendment for hb12
motion allow to
pass okay our vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes clerk votes
yes representative lales yes
representative
yella yes representative Kelly yes
awood yes representative Brown yes
representative
kahill yes representative stavis yes
yes representative Tetro yes
representative elberger yes represent
major yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative Frank yes and Mr
chairman yes motion passes 19 to Z thank
you representative svis do you have a
motion
yes I move ought to pass as amended on
HB
1125 do I have a second on that
representative priest representative
Holland
seconds further discussion on OTP as
amended representative
yella thank you um we just got through
um a bill about allowing uh where people
asked their elected representative
questions about how they voted and
spurring discussion about that and then
in this bill it forbids the asking of
questions um and I think that just as um
you
might
ask I think it should not be against I
should not be against the law to ask the
questions I think the the people have no
responsibility to answer the questions
but I think that um that having the
language in the law saying that no
person shall ask questions of any
commissioner or delegation member I feel
like that is kind of going down the
wrong road um and so especially in in in
placing that in the right to know
section of law in our uh I think that's
especially problematic and so so I don't
I don't support that um I don't think
that that there is any
punishments um if someone does answer
the qu ask the question so um I think
it's just the principle of the issue of
being transparent and not and and not
that you know this person's going to get
arrested or whatever for for asking a
question that's unlawful to ask
so represent represent priest do you
have your hand up yes I do go ahead
thank you Mr chairman um within the
three minutes um that they're allowed to
speak they can they can ask all the
questions they want to the commission
members in their comments and whether or
not the commission members or the
delegation choose to answer them that's
up to them but they do have the right to
ask the questions thank
you representative Elward
thank you Mr chairman I'm confused um
being a newbie to being a delegation
member I go to the
meeting um they have the business
portion then they have a public
comment um
portion and then they open the floor to
questions or or actually before the
public
comment they have uh each member of the
department Department come up and
explain their position and at that point
they open up
questions um so I'm I'm confused by
forbidding
questioning for the comments represent k
k Hill you had your hand up thank you Mr
chair I'm I'm just going to read the
line 13 for us it say no person shall
ask questions of any commission or
delegation member
so it does actually say what
representative
you representative
power thank you Mr CH thank you Mr
chairman
um I'd like to support this amendment
and it's unfortunate that there is that
sentence um specifying that no person
shall ask a question of any commissioner
or delegation member I would be able to
support this Amendment if that was not
in the amendment and like the
representative priest had mentioned that
the person um providing public input
they should be able to say what they
want even if it's in the form of a
question there's no obligation for a a
commissioner or a delegation member to
to respond and answer that question but
I don't feel that it should be
prohibited thank
you represent sa uh thank you Mr chair
and thank you colleagues for your
valuable input I'm sure that the prime
sponsor would be happy to have this
amended Amendment amended um and I would
be happy to take that phrase out um
probably could do so this afternoon I
don't know what that would do to our
schedule Mr chair but I would be happy
to take that phrase out
we no we haven't voted
no
no we currently have a
motion and a
second so I believe
we let's take a we've got time let's
take about a 5 minute recess here while
I think about
this okay um never mind everybody back
so we have already voted on the
amendment the amendment has already been
put in so we are actually on a ought to
pass as amended motion so the amendment
has already replaced the bill so we are
voting
on HB 1125 as amended by 2024
0784 represent k
this is just a question of the chair are
we allowed to make a motion to
reconsider our our vote on the
amendment a we have to vote we have to
complete this vote here
um would
it Mr chair another question no
still think about your first one well
could could the person that made the
motion the motion reconsider their
motion right
now hold
on I don't know 5 minute
recess call call the
clerk
e
e e
okay here let's go
guys so here
is once everybody is
listening here is what we are going to
do we are in the middle of this vote I
was unable to get hold of Paul but uh
the amendment has already been passed
the current motion is to pass as amended
I'm going to suggest we continue on we
will vote on
this just like the other bill that
representative um that I spoke about
represent power is correct we need to be
consistent here um I would say if this
passes a floor amendment can be done I
don't want to start retracting votes and
doing all this stuff I think we need to
be consistent we push forward with where
we are and if uh if it passes now then
representative
uh stavis or whoever can do a floor
amend very simple floor amendment to
make this
go representative
lus yes and I I am addressing
representative
stavis do you know what the intent of
the amendment was it seems to me and and
representative priest and I had a short
discussion on this it seems to me that
we want people in the public comment
period to be able to ask
questions this sentence seems to throw
that out the window but perhaps the
intent was that a person could ask a
question but of the body as a whole not
toward a specific
individual I think that's fairly correct
I know at our committee uh delegation
meetings
uh we have public comment periods but we
do not and we make clear or the chairman
of the committee makes clear at the
beginning this is for public comment on
only this is not for asking questions
that's how we operate it I think this is
attempting to get to that but I think it
could be probably a little bit clearer
that's why I'd just like to say we move
on uh and then this if it passes the uh
representative sais can put a floor and
representative stavis thank you Mr chair
I think representative lelis was asking
me a question with that um and yes
you're absolutely right the answer to
that question is yes the intent of that
language although inartfully drafted I
will admit it to prevent a kind of back
and forth tit fortat with individual
delegation or commission members uh and
in our planning board and on our city
council we make that very clear at the
outset of the public comment section um
so I'm happy to offer a floor amendment
should this bill go forward that would
strike this language or create better
language that we can all agree on but I
agree that we should be consistent and
go forward with the process we've
already we're already in the middle of
this
bill repres uh represent power thank you
Mr chairman so um
on House Bill 1359 I offered a floor
Amendment it it failed then the motion
went forward ought to pass and then
after that was a vote was taken the
chairman said well if the amendment had
been written
differently
Etc we're this is this I see this as the
same this the same scenario that that's
we're facing right now and I would say
that there absolutely is no guarantee
that anybody's is going to file a floor
Amendment and I would also
um also State very firmly that this
committee we need to vote on what is in
front of us right here and now and not
something that we think you know might
manifest you know in the future in
another body or on the floor
um I would really
um say that people need to think about
that so I don't recommend
um to cast a vote otherwise um based on
anything else but what is in front of us
here right now thank
you representative
Gallagher um so just since there seems
to be a lot of um confusion about the no
person shall ask questions of any
commission or delegation member I'd just
like to note that that was in the
original bill as un amended to so um
that's not something that um that's not
something that the amendment introduced
so um withdrawing the amendment wouldn't
remove it or anything it would require
another amendment anyways um so okay
what what I'd like to do here can we
speak more uh if so we can get going on
it to the the bill itself and not the
process the process we already decided
how how it's going to go forward we will
vote on what is here and that's it
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman um to address a couple of
comments um I will vote for this bill as
amended and I have faith in my fellow
members of the committee that a member
will forward a floor amendment to
correct the issue of clarity on that
line item thank you representative kill
would like to Echo my colleagues
comments um I will be voting for this um
and I would ask for help from someone to
help me do a floor amendment I will do
the floor Amendment and I've never done
one and I will do the floor Amendment
represent
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will also be
voting uh for this bill I think it's
very important that it's specific in the
state statutes that people are allowed
to
talk thank you thank you further
questions comments seeing thatone we'll
ask the clerk to call a roll on HBU
1125 as amended
OTP okay our vice chairman power
no representative guthy yes click votes
no representative silus
yes representative Keller
no representative Kelly yes
representative
howood
yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
stavis yes representative T yes
representative elberger
yes uh representative Mai yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes yes representative priest
yes representative Frank yes and Mr
chairman
yes otpa passes
16-3 okay
16-3 um majority report representative
stavis I believe you'll be writing is
there objections to going on the consent
calendar
representative yo object so it will not
go on consent um who would like to write
The Minority Report on
this representative Kella
okay okay with that that closes the
exact session on
11:25 it is quarter of noon and we start
our house
hearings at 100 p.m. so we we will see
everybody
then
wom he gave me a space so
I right finard last
very
interesting e
whoever was running against
Reagan
e
e e
you guys
okay welcome back everybody it's uh 1:00
and we will go ahead and open up the
public hearing on
HB hold on a second I just
thought okay uh open up the hearing on
hb13 1971 relative to allowing the land
use master plan to include a section on
waste
reduction and I believe would that be
representative eel or Eble eel excellent
okay you have the floor okay well thank
you very much um chair turot and thank
you to the committee for having me today
to discuss this bill my name is Karen
eel and I represent uh marac District
7 which is New London and
Newbury so I come uh to you today with
HB
1371 but I'm here in my capacity uh as
the chair of New Hampshire's um Solid
Waste working group which I don't think
I've been here before I haven't really
discussed this with your committee but
it is a stakeholder committee that
represents um many people from different
parts of the state concerning um solid
waste so we have landfill operator on
there
municipalities um folks in charge of
recycling um a representative of the
governor it's a very broad group um and
our primary charge under the statute is
to work with Dees in support of
achievement of the newly issued as in um
October of 2022 Solid Waste Management
plan which outlines a lot of uh of the
goals for the state on how to do better
on solid waste and I think you all know
that's been a pretty hot topic around
here lately um we do have as of uh a
year or so ago new Solid Waste diversion
goals meaning the amount of solid waste
you're trying to keep out of landfills
and incinerators our goal is to have a
25% reduction in weight by 2030 and a 45
% reduction in weight by um
2050 and uh obviously landfills and
their capacity is a big issue so one of
the goals is to try to keep as much as
we can out of the landfills so that we
can uh retain it for New Hampshire solid
waste so in many ways municipalities are
really in the front lines of this effort
and um it's a really important role that
municipalities
uh have to fulfill on behalf of their uh
their constituency in fact uh there's a
letter here from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association in support of this
uh Bill and they clar they put very
clearly in there that it is a statutory
responsibility of municipalities to um
take care of the solid waste for their
for their folks in fact my first
involvement and where a lot of this uh
Solid Waste interest rest has was
generated was uh several years ago when
China said they weren't going to take
our plastic and mixed paper anymore and
municipalities were really floundering
trying to figure out what to do with it
so they really are in the front lines
and uh it is a big expense for a lot of
them so many of the goals in the solid
waste management plan involve
municipalities we are encouraging them
and supporting their education efforts
diversion work and um citizens really
are paying attention to what's happening
with their trash so that's um how the
solid waste working group actually came
to uh suggest that we introduce House
Bill
1371 and it's a simple Bill and what it
would do it would
um amend the section of the statute that
currently outlines the optional portions
of the master plan so I'm sure you guys
are all very familiar with it but
sometimes it's helpful to just have the
statute in front of you so I gave you um
a copy of the statute so the statute is
broken up into the things that are
optional and the things that are
required and just myself and as a group
we were really really surprised to see
such an important statutory
responsibility from for municipalities
isn't even included Ed in the the topic
of planning for solid waste isn't even
included in the optional portions of the
master
plan so we thought that that was a
really important thing given everything
else and their statutory
responsibilities that we do put it in
the master plan um I want to emphasize
here that it's a well-known fact in the
state of New Hampshire that towns only
have the powers that are granted to them
by the State and we've seen that in in
in many different contexts whether it's
been guns speed limits uh you know just
about anything
and I think that it would be very
important for the towns do very
specifically have stated in the statute
that they have the option of putting um
waste
reduction in their in their master plan
so I have a couple of other uh support
letters here one is from the Northeast
resource recovery Association those
folks talk about being on the front
lines they're working with
municipalities all the time in the
development of their recycling plans and
uh contracts they support this bill
there's also something here from the
conservation law foundation and there's
generally uniform uh recognition that
Solid Waste is a big Topic in New
Hampshire right right now and
municipalities should be encouraged to
focus on it and also give the be given
the option to put it in their master
plan and with that um I'd be happy to
take any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for being well
prepared especially by delivering the
rsas that's very good uh representative
gallager uh so hi uh thanks for
introducing um so so my first reaction
is just this seems like a pretty obvious
addition um do you know why it wasn't
already listed there was it just an
oversight or was there a particular
reason for leaving it out I mean I
honestly had the same question I and
because I was looking through just just
in thinking uh with the solid waste
working group about you know what we're
trying to achieve here I actually was on
a planning board in my town for 20 years
and so and I survived um but I it led me
to look at the master plan statute and I
honestly was rather shocked uh that
waste uh reduction and Solid Waste
Management isn't in here and I just have
to believe that that it's oversight
without
um I I just want to say that there are
things in here that you know when you
compare them to Solid Waste Management I
would really like to have Solid Waste
Management in here I think it's a
glaring um glaring
absence representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony
um I you said you've been on a planning
board for a long time so I don't know
what town it is and uh New London okay I
don't know what happens to your plan
your master plan after you do it some
some communities it it goes into a
bottom
draw um I could you tell me why it
wouldn't be better to keep the solid
waste subject which is so important and
cost the town so much money to keep it
as it is now separate and have a a
separate plan in each Community instead
of lap overlapping it in into the master
plan
well uh F let's see I would just start
out by saying that if there's any
community that wants to focus
exclusively on their Solid Waste
Management in a really big way that
would be a fantastic idea but like many
communities um you know they have so
many other things that they're doing the
master plan requirement is a requirement
they're supposed to do it I realize they
don't all do it um but uh
I think that putting it in the plan
gives um an opportunity to build on that
for the future I I mean I guess I would
say I was on the on the um planning
board for 20 years and I chaired it for
the last 10 and we really any actions
that we took we they were very much
grounded in the master plan and I think
I mean that's really the way it's
supposed to be and any town that is
going to all the effort of developing a
master plan certainly shouldn't be just
putting it in the bottom drawer um and
so I I agree with you on that but I I
and I guess I would also say that if you
put something shorter in the master plan
then that would be a really good vehicle
to build on to develop an independent
plan for your town thank you thank you
Mr chair representa
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question do
you think it's fair to say that the
evolution of the master plan
statute evolves with time and that as
issues come to the four they ought to be
included because they weren't at the
four in Prior
eras
um electric vehicle charging stations
for example um land use for alternative
energy reduction for example waste
reduction all these issues are R
frequently recently developing issues
and the master plan
statute takes time for it to become
complete and probably never will be
complete because issues continue to
evolve would you say that that is true
of waste
reduction well just going back to the
beginning of your question yes I think
the master plan section has been
evolving I mean on the
handy dandy statute that I I passed out
to you you can see all the different
times that it's been amended um I would
say just as a general matter waste
reduction and solid waste management is
just a really basic uh function of a
town and I mean even though time moves
on to get back to representative
Gallagher's comment it really should
have been here right from the beginning
I think but that also shows you that in
many cases it's like the poor stepchild
or whatever of you know a lot of people
don't think so much about it but it's
really important and so by putting it in
here it's a real statement from the
state that says yes you should be
focusing on this um and I would just go
back again to the point that I mean I
just was in another committee uh working
on an issue that allowed municipalities
to have a little a little bit more
control over their speed limits and
clearly in that case as here they only
have the authority that we grant them so
it's in some ways alarming that the
authority to have the option to put
waste reduction um in your master plan
isn't even in our statutes
representative lales were you going to
speak yes Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um you shouldn't you
should feel at home here we have a lot
of solid waste in this committee but uh
one I'll try to come back one of the
questions that I have that approximately
25% of solid waste is wet
garbage and if we were able for there
was a time in my life when I I used
Russian red worms to eat that solid
garbage because I felt that it's great
when you take a negative and make a
positive out of it and if do you know in
your travels working in this in this
area whether there's any sort of
um uh initiative toward recycling of wet
garbage
into uh on one of my favorite subjects
representative um we actually one of the
big things that we've worked on in the
solid waste working group is promotion
of better handling of food waste which I
think is what you mean um and I mean
again coming back to towns this is a way
that towns can start to get a handle on
the Tipping fees and the and the
processing issues um because 25% you're
right of of in weight of what's going
into our landfills is in fact food waste
and um we're really trying to do more
education concerning food waste uh
someone is here from Dees they can talk
to you about that but you know it starts
in many cases while while laying out a
plan I mean in our town we're now doing
composting it's worked out great but we
started out with a with a poll and we
tried to find out whether people were
interested in it and then we also
established a waste reduction committee
which I'm not on but anyway um it's just
really helpful to do more planning for
precisely that reason and we should be
doing more composting it's a waste of um
our landfill space and also of organic
matter that could otherwise be used
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman for and
thank you for taking my question what is
the magnitude of solid w waste problem
in New Hampshire now in our
communities well that's a really big uh
question I would say there's too much of
it um I think that uh we really should
be doing more reuse we should be doing
more
recycling um and you know
that that will save communities money
but it also um is a better use of
products rather than throwing them away
I mean I think we I don't know we could
talk about this for a really long time
repres yes if we could I we could kind
of bring our Focus back to the subject
matter please and may I may can we do it
please go ahead regarding the master
plan
um are there protocols that communities
can
use to um address these various elements
of Sol waste like recycling wet
waste
landfills uh you name it um thank you I
think education is a huge piece of what
we're trying to accomplish at the state
level Dees is developing protocols
Regional planning commissions have
protocols the New Hampshire uh resource
recovery Association works very closely
with towns to develop protocols um but
you know it does start with planning and
it's really really um a key point and I
just think it's incredibly important to
get this into the master plan statute
are there any questions discussing about
the putting this into the master plan y
Mr uh representative
yella thank you uh thank you for taking
the question um
so from your testimony it seems like
you ha your interpretation of the
statute um may be that
the that the Planning and Zoning people
can only do um only have sections in it
which are listed um and not that they
may have may have whatever they want as
long as they do the
requirements um
and it also seems like you are saying
that it is extremely important that the
state encourage them to do this um so I
guess my question
is is the first part of
my my belief that your interpretation of
the statute is correct that you're not
able to currently have any language in
your your um master plan regarding this
and and if it is super important by by
the state then shouldn't it be in the
required section and not in the optional
section so can you talk a little bit
about that um i' I'd be happy to I mean
I don't think it's just my opinion that
the optional part of this is basically
the framework that a community has to
deal with I mean this is a Dylan's rule
state and either you believe believe
that towns only have the ability to do
what the state gives them allows them to
do or you don't I mean you can't like
pick and choose when that law applies
and when it doesn't so that's number one
number two you
know as a legislator and and as a member
of this fine body sure I would like to
come in here and ask you to put it into
the required section I think it's really
important but I just looking at what's
in the required section now they're
really Global topics um it seemed to me
that the best approach to start with is
to put it in the optional section but
you know I defer to the committee if you
want to make it required it's certainly
all right with
me S Holland so my question thank you
for taking my question uh so my question
really revolves right right now at least
in my community uh and I was on our
Solid Waste program for a long time
it really resides in the budgetary uh
section so we've been reacting to the
fluctuations in commodity prices and
we're trying to figure out how to get
rid of stuff out of the landfill and
also make it economically viable so it
so we're already working on it are we
going to gain more by putting it in the
master plan does that help us more with
the strategic planning uh because we're
already in the you know when we're doing
the budgeting it sits in our Capital
Improvement and we talk about new trucks
and all the equipment are we going to
gain a lot more if we do put it in the
master plan I guess is what I'm asking
well I would say that's your town you
know I mean a lot of towns uh they're
not as focused on it as maybe you would
be but I mean if you look at the ex I
mean like in my town we're talking about
a new police station we're talking about
more different Zoning for you know
housing a lot of the the continuing
conversations whether they're based on
whether it revolves funding or zoning or
whatever should be grounded in a plan
that's been developed by a over time
with a lot of input and I realize the
budget uh process does have you know
people that get involved in the budget
process but how much better would it be
to have what you're doing grounded in a
in a forward-looking plan um for your
town representative Elwood thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question if putting this in
the required section would that create
an unfunded mandate on the
towns education and Outreach and needs
analysis I mean no I would say no more
than what is already in here but I'm not
sitting here asking you to put it in the
required section oh I understand that
yeah I just you know anyway
representative
Gallagher um so as one of the um
relatively newer members of the
committee uh without quite as much
experience in local government um so
let's say we um we pass this bill as is
and um
now municipalities can include such a um
section in their Master plans how would
I as a member of my community go about
getting my
municipality to include it like how how
would um how would people who um what's
the process for
um what do you think the likelihood is
that um municipalities will actually
make use of this I me ability I in in my
experience municipalities look at this
statute and they see the topics that
they can be discussing I mean they
obviously also look at the Master plans
that they did before but if I was
someone that wanted to engage and get my
town to do something I would go to the
responsible uh governing body you can go
I don't know if you have yeah you have a
planning board in conquered you can go
there you can go to the selectman um you
know and make your voice known just like
you could in any other
topic representative FR thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question um would you say that
the optional sections of a master
plan are more of a a
hint as to what town should put into or
could put into rather than a a
mandate um they're not mandates I think
they're very strong suggestions uh that
the legislature thought strongly enough
about this issue that uh the towns
really should be considering putting
them in and that's why again I come to
where I started it's just kind of
shocking and alarming shocking with a
lowercase s that you wouldn't have
something about Solid Waste in your
master plan it's just seems so
pivotal representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman for allowing me to speak and
thank you for taking my question I have
done numerous Master plans in the past
so many that I've lost count um as a
planner um usually we we would put them
in the community facilities
section um is there an advantage of
having their own section as things to
look at I think absolutely I mean I it
just takes I mean if you're looking at
Community facilities you're probably
looking at police stations and fire
stations schools and stuff like this and
that this can sort of be tucked to the
side um you know but the other thing is
that I would say not everybody puts
trash in the community facilities
section you know I mean they just may
not do it or they might just look at the
transfer station and whether it's big
enough I mean I can see that happening
but whether your transfer station is big
enough really isn't the same thing as um
Solid Waste
Management further questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony I have
another pink card with a Michael
Nor uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Michael norc uh I'm with the New
Hampshire Dees Solid Waste Management
Bureau and I head up the section on
planning uh education and materials
management which is a blanket term for
recycling basically um New Hampshire
Dees does support this effort uh we
believe that planning at the local level
for Waste reduction diversion recycling
all the all of the above is an important
aspect um as representative Eble
mentioned the state issued a solid waste
management plan in late 2022 which kind
of outlines a a vision or a roadmap for
how Solid Waste should be managed
Statewide and um I think it's important
to just realize that that plan is is
Dees will obviously have a central role
in implementing that plan but support
from municipalities through local
planning efforts um would definitely
help to uphold implementation and and
make sure that we're making progress
towards that plan um so de supports it
that's really all I wanted to say if
there are any questions I'm happy to to
address thank you are there any
questions relating to
putting waste reduction section into the
master plan representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question um since the state has its own
plan what is
the what is the concern that um a
municipality has the power to create
their own plan maybe in conflict with
de's plan and trying to kind of work at
Cross purposes um and why wouldn't they
just why wouldn't you just be referring
to the state plan instead of H having a
fractured approach with you know 250
different solutions to the same problem
yeah thank you for the question um I
don't think that it needs to be kind of
duplicative or cross purposes I think
one of the points I was trying to make
is that Dees is going to have a central
role in implementing the solid waste
management plan which is kind of this
overarching 10-year plan um but we're
going to need support we can't do it all
on our own and I think having
municipalities as key players in that
sphere to help support implementation of
the plan um so I think this could be an
opportunity for municipalities to think
more about uh implementing aspects of
the plan in their
own local master plan um so I guess
that's just um that's just how we would
like to see
it further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony I have no more
pink cards on the blue signup sheet I
had the two individuals who spoke
already in favor along with the nhma in
favor having no more pin cards we'll go
ahead and close the hearing on HB 1371
thank
you okay we'll Now open up the hearing
on HB
156 relative to require votes for the
approval issuance of bonds
representative kahill since you're up
and about could you introduce
it good afternoon committee members
great to see you um here today to
introduce uh HB 1506 relative to
required votes to approve Insurance of
bonds I'll take any
questions thank you very much are there
any
questions seeing none we go ahead and
close the hearing on hp56
uh the next one we have is at 1:40 so we
have about 10
minutes e
actually since most people are here and
we have about 10 minutes I just going to
go over a quick note I have here on
potential scheduling for March
okay as of right now the notice just
went out for March 6th which is a
Wednesday we will be doing
that um our last day to have everything
done including committee reports of the
20th so what I'm trying to do is find an
additional two
days um in addition to the 6th prior to
the 20th that we can meet now there's
some conflicts all kinds of things going
on um on the 20th what I'd like to do
with that is hold that one open for us
just in case there's anything that's we
have to finalize we could do in the
morning and get that out so as of now
we're looking at the 6th the next week
um the normally we would do it on a
Tuesday or Wednesday um the Wednesday
unfortunately your chairman has his
Federal jury duty commitment the 12th of
course is the election day so that week
well let me back up if we do not have a
house session on the
7th I'm going to put that down as one of
our um days we will know that probably
tomorrow or the next day whether or not
that's going to go and then we're going
to have to find another day in that that
next week other than the 12th and 13th
the 14th will almost assuredly be a
house session so in that week we would
be looking at and I hate to do it but
either a Monday or a Friday or Poss
possibly the ne no we can't do it the
next week either because the we want to
hold the 20th open just for the morning
so um think about which day is better or
worse for everybody on a Monday or a
Friday I know it sucks
but uh the week of the
11th what's
that
okay why don't you kind of get a feel
for your committee see what they
your members and see what they think and
if we can get it done on the 7th uh if
we can get the sth that would that would
really help just so you know on the six
we're going to hear the last four bills
we have or five and what other than
exing will be
done um and just so everybody's aware it
hasn't I don't think it's gone out yet
on the six we're going to be hearing a
non- gerain bill
um it's going to be a bill on local
options
for casino and horse
racing okay so you need to be prepared
for
that
um that's probably going to be a long
one just so everybody knows that'll be
in the afternoon on the
6th I've spoken to the um the bill that
we're going to use was one of uh
representative Roy's that he's not
pursuing because it's going to be
included in
11:24 and I've already got an approval
from the speaker it it does touch on
Municipal and County um the existing
regs in there has the local option for
approving or disapproving a Kino so this
is nothing more than also having the
local option to approve or disapprove of
those two two issues so just want
everybody be apprised of that that'll be
a kind of an interesting one so anyway
um the sixth hopefully the seventh and
then the following week one of those
days and then we'll we'll use the 20th
for clean up in case we have anything
left that was pretty vague wasn't it
other than the
sixth
sorry
e
e e
okay folks it is40 we're going to go
ahead and open up the public hearing on
HB 1345 relative to the length of terms
for Coos County officers I believe
representative
Davis is here
the prime sponsor you have the floor
Committee hearing is
open thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name's
representative annal Davis I'm from
Miland New Hampshire Coos District 2 and
I'm here to introduce House Bill
1345 this bill will simply change the
length of the term from 2 years to four
years for Coos County
Sheriff County attorney County Treasurer
the register of deeds and the register
of
probate I believe this has already been
enacted in Rockingham County and I I
haven't heard of any push back or or any
apparent issues with that uh for the
record all nine delegation members are
have approved this the three
Commissioners are on board there's
there's been and everybody's in approval
and
Coos uh there's there's a couple of
people that are going to speak behind me
today so if there's any questions they
may be better qualified to answer but
I'll try to answer any questions that
you may have thank
you thank you representative
yella thank you uh thank you for taking
the question um is there any officers in
the state that you oppose having a
four-year term instead of a 2-year term
like
um I mean I can give examples but is
there is there any
uh office that you think should have the
um that addition like the the
responsibility to the voters that it
does now and that we should not move
towards a four-year term for every
elected office in in the state well
thank you for the
question I'm I'm just asking for Coos
County not the entire state but uh I
think what happens for a two-year term
you you get appointed you get elected to
your position you spend probably eight
months to a year trying to learn that
job next thing you know you're running
for election again and I think in some
cases these people may leave a a good
job to take this job and after two years
they're out if you know if it happened
to go that
way follow up thank you couldn't
couldn't you say that same statement
about all of the elected positions that
are 2-year terms in the state like the
governor or the Secretary of State or
state representatives or or Senators
like can you give me an example of why
this the the the voters need less
oversight over these people than than
the other people
interested thank
you yeah I'm not sure I think
that no no when you get up there you can
talk about it I I'll let him if he's
speaking after me I'll let him answer
that for you sorry representative priest
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question on
line um 15 I'm kind of confused by what
it
says um and at each subsequent state
general election any such officer in
Rockingham County is this a mistake that
shouldn't this be
Co County CO yeah
okay
no representative priest that's existing
language oh yes that is exist yeah so
that should be
changed that's not subject of the I see
I I okay thank you for the
clarification thank you Mr J and thank
you for your your testimony I come from
Rockingham County uh and uh could you
tell
me uh these officers how long they have
been holding that term how how long is
this their first they're in there all in
their first term their second term in
other words do they have any seniority
or the experience seemed to be the thing
that was hung on with Rockingham County
the the comment you made that you know
they're there in there that takes them a
year to or so to get going
and then once they're they feel
comfortable because the difference
between these positions is it's a their
jobs right they're not and I hate to say
it like state representatives or
Selectmen or whatever that it's but the
point was made that this was a these
were jobs and I I ask you how long have
they been in their jobs and do you have
is that why you have the confidence in
letting them stay there for 4 years
instead of two years in the future well
we've got a couple of them here to speak
today everybody's been in there at least
one term or two years I believe so yes
that seemed to be one of the strong
points that they had serve their term
they had the experience they just like
in any other job you look at your
employees say Okay gee they're doing a
good job we'll keep them and that was uh
I I don't know if that's the situation
in your county it was in Rockingham
where every one of the those people that
were uh considered for to go to a longer
term was the cost was the cost of the
the running for office and the fact that
they were all in the office for
significant amount of time and they were
experienced in their
job I believe that is the case in Coos
as well thank you
thank you Mr
chair representative
Gallagher um so one of the arguments
that was made in favor of doing this for
Rockingham County was that oh Rockingham
County has such a large population um
that it makes it harder to run campaigns
now kasos county is one of the
smaller counties isn't it so would that
argument still make sense in your case
as
well I don't I don't know if that would
be an effect have an effect on
this representative
uh thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question is it your belief that that
um because Rockingham County has the
ability to do this that Coos County has
the ability to do this and that's what
you guys wish to do well I I was asked
by a lot of the uh these positions if
this would be possible and and we looked
into it and saw that there wasn't a
problem in
Rockingham thought it may be feasible
for
Coos representative
lales yes uh thank you for taking my
question um and I look back at the
arguments that were made for Rockingham
County and one of the one of the reasons
and I'm just asking if in your mind if
it applies to Coos also is that a lot of
these officers have
staffs and the you know the the staff
is equally important as the elected
officer so if the officer was to lose
his job would then would then the staff
be unsettled there is that your
impression you think that applies
believe that's possible yes thank
you forther questions seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony
representative thank you uh next person
up I have is Keith
robers hold on put on your
mic first
time sorry so I actually been with Coos
County since 1998 I've gone through four
sheriffs you can be a sheriff for four
years eight years sometimes Sheriff's
Office and police work Sheriff's Office
and police work kind of it's a different
thing Coos County has actually not as
many people but we have a big land mass
and we don't have the same amount of
people as Rockingham or anybody else so
it's hard to find really good employees
um I think it's very important
I hate to see someone come in for a
two-year term and their first year
they're trying to learn a job the second
year they're trying to keep their job
and and I've watched it because I've
gone through numerous sheriffs um I just
think it's kind of important to get
somebody in there if you can't do the
job in four years then hopefully someone
else will run against them in my
personal opinion and beat them out but
you need four years to actually get your
feet on the ground and actually
understand the position you can be a cop
all day long and our Sheriff now with a
deputy chief great deputy chief he came
in here eye opener we do a ton of
different stuff I can seize your
property I can evict you I can do a
bunch of stuff that the police don't do
so it's very important to get somebody
in there that actually can understand a
job and not have to worry about running
just like you guys have to run all the
time and I just think it's very
important for Coos County because we're
we have a lot of the northern border
you've seen a a lot of opposition
against it you know like putting people
up there because we got a lot of
landmass and not a lot of cops and the
keep
cops it's been a great 26 years and I
just think it's very important to get a
sheriff that can stay for four years and
understand Coos County and actually make
it work
that's testimony
done very good represent power thank you
mic on thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I missed
your your introduction are you with the
sheriff's department in Coos County are
you the sheriff so I'm a captain of the
Sheriff's Office and like I said I've
been on since 1998 and I've gone through
four different sheriffs and seen four
different administrations that does
stuff different
and that's kind of where I think four
years make a big difference because you
can't get it done in two years you you
need to really understand our department
and how it works and and we're not any
other any other County we're unique in
Coos further questions representative
yella do you have a question can you
thank you can you restate what what you
were saying as far as the turnover in
the position um and can you elaborate on
if any of those any of the people and
the positions that we're currently
talking about did not get reelected
after their first term and therefore um
the voters would have would have been
deprived in that situation of making a
quick change where they thought that
there was something going wrong in in
that office thank
you and Coos County doesn't have a big
turnover like if you're a sheriff and
you're doing a good job and it's you a
sheriff does a good job with the people
that he has under him and he has to rely
on the guys that he's that are there a
new sheriff that would my personal
opinion new sheriff comes in and fires
everybody well I think he's the dumbest
Sheriff that's out there because his
guys actually know what's going on
unless they're not good and then you
kind of get rid of them but you don't
really have a big turnover in Coos just
because you don't have a lot of people
that run because we're not a big County
peoplewise but we're a big County
landwise wise and it's hard to keep good
people and we have good people so I
think the deputies have done a great job
just helping the sheriff be
successful if that answers your question
that kind
of go ahead represent thank you can you
specifically state it to your knowledge
has there been anyone in Coos County
that has only served one term and then
got voted out by the by the voters thank
you so you have Sheriff Lovin that
started Coos County full-time in
1998 he I think he did a term maybe two
I'm not sure at that point um Chief Al
came in he did one term and he actually
said this isn't for me he didn't like
the politics of it didn't like the Civil
part of it he said this isn't being a
cop and he actually got elected sheriff
and resigned and that's how Jerry maku
got in and Jerry maku is Sheriff who was
a State Trooper local PD went through
and he got to a point where he did I
think eight years and said I've had it
I'm done and then that's when the
current Sheriff Brian valerino who the
deputy chief stepped in ran and he's
been there since so I've watched him
come and go it's it's not for everybody
it's a it's a hard position um it's
really taxing
F the question represent majori thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um and I and I think I heard
you corre correctly talking about the
challenges that that uh that law
enforcement has up at the border and and
I'm wondering this bill we've had this
bill many many times in Municipal and
County to about all of the same
positions but am I hearing that that Co
am I hearing correctly the Coos County
has that much more pressure for the
sheriff and the County Attorney possibly
because of and I'm not and I'm not
saying the emergent border issue but the
the the just having to control the
border that make any sense it does I
don't think it has anything to do with
the border the border on the election
part you know what the border is the
Border it's we have a lot of Woodland if
we've done a lot with stone garden
everything else we're we're out there a
lot you can't cover that so I don't
think it really has anything to do with
the election part it just has to do with
getting someone in that can understand a
job and personally being here since 98 I
really believe it takes you four years
to actually understand this job and like
said not that I haven't been around and
I've been in Coos County I haven't left
I've had plenty of opportunities I love
Coos County and but it takes you time
and it's it's it's a lot of work to be a
sheriff thank you forur the questions
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question in your in
your
estimation and having been there as long
as you have what is the approximate cost
the of the learning curve of these
positions two versus four
years learning
curve it's hard to describe
every every county is different
Rockingham County does Patrol they every
County we're a small County we don't
have the opportunity to say hey you're
going to do Roar Patrol you're going to
do our guys do transports they do civil
rits we evict people we take kids from
their parents like we do it all and and
it is taxing and it's but we're not like
any other County and that personally
like I said four years you're going to
get a sheriff that will know this job in
four years you're either going to get it
or you're not and if you don't get it
then the people are going to vote you
out or you're going to run again and say
I want this that's my personal opinion
forther
question representative
fra thank you Mr chair um if I
understand you correctly you are an
employee rather than elected is that
correct correct follow
up um as an employee
when you get a new
sheriff how disruptive is that or is
that disruptive to your job as the new
sheriff learns his
job so I've been lucky because I've had
good Sheriff that came in but it could
be very disruptive and I've seen other
counties that I'm not going to name that
sheriffs have come in and disrupted the
whole County and we don't have that in
Coos it's worked very well in Coos but
our we've worked very well together and
the sheriffs that been elected have
lived in Coos County they've worked the
whole County they understand how the
county works so we've been lucky in
Coos further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony than we have uh Brian
ballerino
when you introduce yourself could you
also say I'm assuming you're in favor
but uh who you are specifically and what
your title is yes thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Brian valerino I'm currently the high
Sheriff of coest County um I had a lot
of talking points but seems like my
captain covered pretty much all of them
so I I appreciate that um I just just a
little bit of background I guess is is
what I can uh offer you uh now um I did
my entire career with Berlin PD ended up
by being the deputy chief I did 26 years
I went from the criminal world to when I
retired to the Civil World um so that
was a whole different learning process
for me uh when the captain pointed out
that um it takes a while to learn the
job it was an eye opener because I
wasn't used to that um luckily I had
great staff uh that we accomplished a
lot of goals that I had um I didn't have
any disruptions I didn't lose anybody um
to another agency or anything like that
you know you got to go in there it's
like any other job if you want to change
things you got to make change a little
bit slow because if you don't it's going
to upset the whole apple cart so we were
able to do that but I am in favor of of
this bill it um doesn't affect me
personally at this point because this is
my last term um and the captain is going
to be running for uh for uh the high
Sheriff position but I fully support
that um especially when I got there as
Sheriff there were some training and
equipment needs that needed to be done
um I had set some goals up and there's
no way I could have done that in in uh
in two years I was fortunate that I
didn't have anybody run against me um so
with that respect that was uh that was
good but you're always thinking about
about it every I just don't think that
two years is is enough but again it has
no impact on me personally but I think
that
having a four-year term you can set
those goals realistically and not try
and cram everything in um within a
two-year
period questions representative
lales yes I thank you very much for your
testimony and thanks for your service um
I think Coos County is unique when you
look at the counties in New Hampshire I
mean we have the border which has
already been touched upon but you also
have a lot of
unincorporated uh areas you have towns
without police departments so the the
job of the sheriff's
department in in Coos is unique
and and in my way of thinking your
testimony and I I just like your
thoughts on it it does require the extra
uh the extra time the four years uh and
I'd like you to comment on
that thank you Robert yes you're
absolutely right Coos is unique and
we're unique as a law enforcement
Community as well I mean we get along
Ong great with State Police with the
locals um with with Berlin PD we need to
be there for each other because it's not
like Southern New Hampshire where you're
going to have people coming all over the
place but you need to have that buyin
from from your citizens in Co County so
you gotta you got to go out into the uh
unincorporated areas you got to meet
these people and um as the captain said
I mean yes we are a small population up
there but the county is big and uh when
when we don't have trans sports or civil
we try and send people out uh in the
unincorporated areas and um I I think
we've made great strides with that so I
hope that answers your question thank
you thank
you excuse me representative Elward
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir for
your service and time today um do you
happen to remember in the last election
whether or not the treasurer the
register of deeds and the probate ran uh
unopposed
or I'm sorry representative I can't I
know the uh uh the register of deeds is
here um I do know the County Attorney
ran
unopposed and I want to say the
treasurer was unopposed but that one I
can't be 100% sure of okay thank you yes
further questions representative yella
thank you um I keep on hearing a lot of
talk about how it's going to be easier
for the officials um however I haven't
heard anyone talk about the
um TFI the importance or the the lack of
importance of
uh of the cutting in half of the the the
power of the electorate to make a change
in those offices is what do you see as
the um the
drawbacks from the the power of the of
the voters to be able to make a change
in that office if they see it's going
arai especially let's say in the the
the the the sheriff's office that um
could elect someone that has no uh law
enforcement experience at all and so if
they chose to elect that person and then
it was going arai that they want to
change course in two years and wouldn't
be able to for another two years if this
was to pass can you speak a little bit
to that and the risk it there is to the
the voting
population I think this checks and
balances with with every position um as
again I I'll say Co county is unique you
have to get out there you have to know
the people you have to answer the
people's complaints if there's any
complaints um and I think that that is
what is is
really makes Coos successful and that's
why I I believe that it should be a
four-year term um I get out there as
much as I can to the different
communities I believe I'm the only
sheriff in in the state of New Hampshire
that has a marked Cruiser that I like to
bring out to the
various towns in in the area but again
you need to have buying you need to have
the citizens trust you but there also
needs to be a uh a form where if there
is a complaint that it needs to be
investigated but I truly believe by
getting a four-year term you're going to
have someone that's going to be vested
uh in that position because they're
going to know that they're going to be
there for four years or they should be
if they're doing a good
job further questions seeing none thank
you for your testimony thank you next up
we have the honorable Leon R
out welcome former rep
thank
you uh Leon put on your mic thank you
I'm Leon R out I live in Lancaster which
is up in Coos County I did serve two
terms here in the New Hampshire house
very proud of and I currently serve as
the Coos County Register of
Deeds I ran for that position back in
2018 when the current register was going
to
retire the employees that were in in the
office which would normally probably
fill that
position felt it was disadvantageous to
them to run for the elected position
rather than stay as an employee of the
county I was
approached and told that they thought i'
would be a good fit so I did some
research and figured I was willing to
give it a
try but there was definitely hesitation
in that because you're running for a
position that you don't really know and
you have a lot to learn and it's only
two
years so I took the
position love the position actually a
lot of history in the registry of deeds
so it it's a great position I love
history the position though
takes probably two to three years to
actually
learn so about a year and a half into my
first term instead of concentrating on
the job at hand I needed to shift back
into election
mode election mode in Coos County is
maybe a little different than most
places but not a lot other than you got
a lot of territory to cover uh someone
asked about some
cost typically on an election in Coos
County I have spent $2 to
$33,000 during the the
election so that's an expense out of my
pocket plus the candidate or the person
doing the job now has to focus on
reelection rather than the job so that's
why I support this bill because it will
give you four years of continuity and
being able to learn the
position I will also say because there's
been some concern on the voters being
able to make a change if it is needed in
the office office I find one of the
reasons why we have a problem maybe with
less qualified candidates is you're
asking somebody to step outside of their
regular job I had to take a my business
down to just a small part-time to take
this
position it's a big leap of faith to do
something like that or leave another
profession when you're own guaranteed a
job for 2 years there's absolutely no
job security and I believe we would get
better candidates to run for these
offices if they were looking at a
four-year commitment rather than just a
two-year and basically it's a two-ear
Sprint because the two years goes by
quickly as you all know
here so I think we might get better
candidates person would be able to get
better acclimated to the job and learn
the position better in for you
years and then make a decision a really
informed decision on whether it is a
good fit for
them I question was also asked of one of
the previous Witnesses about unopposed
candidates I did run unopposed last
election the first two terms I did I was
opposed but I can say they they weren't
close
elections on last time we'll see what
happens this time but I'm looking
forward to
it I would take any questions at this
time because I don't want to belabor the
point keep it short and sweet let's put
it that way thank you do I see have any
questions representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question if you ran a post
osed what were your campaign
costs I mean unopposed I'm sorry um you
if you're running for an office you
still got to get out there and meet the
people I still ran ads both in the
newspapers on Facebook and did certain
campaign events just to let people know
that I am still interested in the job
and it's a job that I wanted
followup thank you for taking this
follow-up question could
you estimate for for me and for us how
much time you think it took out of your
job uh to to do to run this campaign and
to to run for
re-election the unopposed time it was
probably I spent about 20 hours a
week after work so that's working 40
hours and then doing campaign events the
opposed elections I was probably doing
closer to 30 or 40
hours because it's more intensitive you
actually have somebody that's running
against you um I always take every
election serious whether I've got an
opponent or not and in the words of the
late great Ray Burton you always run
like your three votes behind
for the questions representative o Kella
thank you um thank you for taking the
question it seems like the the a lot of
the
sentiments um being espoused here seem
to be against the election process as a
whole and that that these would be
better served to not be elected
positions um can you talk about that and
with if you if you disagree with that
and and and and believe that it's
important that these El these positions
specifically be elected and and uh that
let's say a 8-year term would be
unreasonable in some some sense thank
you yes I 100% disagree with that I the
register of deeds position in my mind
needs to be elected because one of the
first things that I ran into when I
became Register of Deeds was people that
I had made unhappy because they was
submitting documents that weren't
fitting the bill that they were going to
complain to my County Commissioners and
I plainly told them I don't work for the
County Commissioners I work for the
voters of Coos County that's an
important distinction any of these
elected offices have to make the
four-year term is a better fit for
people to learn to have job security to
get better candidates to actually stand
up and say okay I know I can at least
have this office for four years where if
it's only for two years they're not
going to leave a job and take this on
where it might only be two years in
8-year term would definitely be too long
I think too long of a commitment for
most people four years they can learn
the job figure out if they like the job
and in then either step down or rerun
and again a lot of it is
for continuity where you learn the
position and there's not changes every
year or every two years to what the
registry of deeds in my case is doing
it's very important people understand
what's an acceptable document what when
they come to the registry of deeds what
they're going to be required to have and
if you're changing every two years it
becomes very confusing and kind of messy
when they come into the
office thank you forther questions I see
none thank you rep former representative
R
out I have one more card uh Kate
Horan thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I'm from
the New Hampshire Association of
counties the association is in support
of this bill um just to provide a little
background to this committee uh in
2022 the this committee had actually
passed House Bill 1397 to apply to all
counties that was amended on the house
floor and it was stated on the house
floor that if a County wanted this for
their County they should bring it
individually I've included the link to
the discussion with the timestamp so you
don't have to watch the entire entire
session and you can quickly find that
discussion um this would bring Coos in
line with Rockingham County um these
positions are primarily administrative
and ensuring continuity for the voters
that they know what to expect out of
these positions that are making
administrative decisions and not
necessarily policy decisions is an
important factor for uh these uh
constitutional officers um also uh uh
the association did want me to highlight
that asking these people to immediately
start running for office again takes
away from the services that these people
are supposed to be contributing to their
jobs that they've been elected to happy
to take any questions um and I will
conclude my testimony thank you for the
questions or any questions for uh
representative please do not promote me
uh go
ahead in in Your Capacity with the
County
Association Rockingham has made the
change based upon
your uh how do you feel they're doing uh
they I've discussed this with Rockingham
County they believe this is going well
um it has created some stability for
those offices not only employees but
voters as well um and so the association
has taken the position that if any other
County wants to do this we will support
them in that endeavor thank
you represent yella thank you um you you
said that that it's been um positive um
and you seem to indicate that you had um
talked to not just the people who
benefit from it but also the voters what
kind of
um uh
polling or what is the scope of that
because obviously I wasn't pulled and
I'm I'm not in FA favor of the
Rockingham uh one so how many people uh
do you kind of like I understand the
question thank you representative yella
I was speaking only into my scope as
working with uh the association of
counties and so the Commissioners your
appointed officials um so isn't just
those four positions um we have not done
any polling that is not within our
budget we run a very lean ship so that
is not something we are capable of doing
at this
point Thank you further questions seeing
none thank you for your testimony I just
got one more pink card uh representative
Kelly thank you uh thank you Mr chair uh
I as the Lan Democrat in our uh mids
from cost County here I just want to
present myself to the committee in case
I could make this a nonpartisan issue um
I agree with the the speakers um I don't
see any problem I think that that the
Coos County usually um operates pretty
um apolitical in those offices um and uh
I I support this this motion I will I
will push back on M Mr R out's uh
testimony about uh close elections uh it
was my mom who ran against him in four
years ago and I think she would take uh
Umbridge with the fact of be saying it
wasn't that close 4555
so that's a pretty nice
[Laughter]
spread questions for representative
Kelly seeing none thank you for your
testimony all right I have no more pink
cards we have a blue sheet with about
eight or nine who have signed in it
looks like all from
the uh County of Coos in favor so with
that we'll go ahead and close the
pairing on HB
1345 and give us about 2 minutes and
we'll open up the next one
okay we're going to go ahead and open up
uh the hearing on HP 526 regulating the
use of temporary control Personnel um
this is a recommit bill so it has
already been addressed or or introduced
so we don't need to go through that
again uh so what we will do now is look
for any pink cards couple pink cards
okay thank
Youk in okay I have two pink cards
anybody who wishes to speak make sure
you do fill out one of these uh I have
first up Mark
Bowden sorry good afternoon members of
the committee my name is uh Mark Bodwin
I am a uh retired police officer I did
22 years in uh law enforcement uh both
at the local level and at the state
level
uh currently I am an attorney um I
practice uh with the office of Milner
and krupsky and we represent uh mostly
uh police and fire and some other uh
different types of unions I'm here to uh
speak um in opposition to uh HB
526 uh for a number of reasons um I'm
going first go to uh touched on the
point that nothing's broken and nothing
needs to be fixed so the way the things
are currently working in regards to
police details uh there aren't any real
issues out there uh this bill is just
you know in search of a problem to fix
and there we don't seem to have that
here so I want to First say that the
current uh system is working and so
which leads me to my second point which
I'm afraid that this bill if passed
would uh result in uh some unattended
consequences and some of that uh I think
is just uh from the language itself
um even with the amended uh
version uh line four a city or town
shall only use local Law Enforcement
Officers for temporary traffic control
when there are specific safety concerns
about the project uh my concern here is
in line four shall only well that
doesn't give you any discretion uh it
tells you what you have to do and you
don't have a choice there it's not a May
and in line five specific safety
concerns is pretty vague I'm not I'm not
entirely sure what that means how you
define that um I I think there'd be a
lot of questions there so what and the
other thing that this looks like it it
probably does is kind of make some
confusion as to okay who is going to
make these decision is it the city or
town council is it the police chief
that's in that city or town so you get
some confusion there uh this really
limits your local control uh currently
towns can uh decide what they choose to
do in in this current instance It's
usually the police chief that uh makes
those
decisions um so again with the language
being vague um and uh you know the
limiting of local control uh the New
Hampshire Police Association which I'm a
member of and am currently representing
for on this particular instance uh would
ask that uh you know you uh defeat this
uh bill and with that I'm willing to
take any questions I didn't want to take
up a lot of your time thank you
representative
Gallagher um
so you mentioned testifying to this bill
as amended how so if I remember
correctly we had a previous amend
Amendment to the bill the last time um
we exacted it and now there is a new
amendment in front of us um 2024 r211 H
so could you just clarify to us um which
um which amendments language you're
looking at um or you're basing your
testimony
on can you just go read the amendment
again the number uh
2024 uh
0211 H is the new one that's in front of
us on the back table there's a bunch of
copies if you need
one got it
okay so yeah I see the other one but um
I had reviewed actually this one first
and then I had gotten this one second
and I thought that one was the revised
one but even with this one
um again it shall only be required when
municipality has determined the traffic
volume roadway Vis visibility again
who's determining that um so there is
some you know vagueness there as well
um and
again the concerns here are it's not
broken why are we fixing it uh and with
the unintended consequences the other
question I would have here too is I mean
let's take it a step further with uh
private companies so if a private
company wants to uh hire a police
officer instead of a flagger are they
now Limited in doing that um and it so
again what we see here is I think you're
taking away local control when this is
not something that really needs needs to
be addressed at this point uh is it this
has been working for uh for years so
representative yo Kella thank you thank
you for taking this question sure
um I'm not I don't remember if you I
don't remember you uh testifying last
time um regarding this bill but it
seemed like the the problem that it's
fixing is
municipalities um essentially padding
their police budgets by requiring
flaggers in unnecessary or uh police
Personnel to be used in unnecessary
situations so that they can uh give
their employees more pay um
so do with that scope in mind do you see
that that that is an appropriate thing
that municipality should be able to do
or you think that the um um local
tyranny has gone too far in that sense
and that the municipality should be
reigned in by the state in that case
well I think you have a bunch of um
different issues you have there you know
again this is a local issue it goes down
to the uh local level and you do have
some instances um and again I'm not in
on the administrative side so I can't
speak to what uh I can only tell you to
what I understand happens which is
normally you have the fee for whatever
the police officer is for their hourly
rate uh and then the town will sometimes
and I say sometimes because I'm not
entirely sure all towns do it uh will
add in a um an administrative fee or
also maybe even a cruiser fee if the CW
if the company is requesting that a
cruiser uh accompany the detail as well
too and that's for the use of the
cruiser the fuel the wear and tear on it
and such um I'm not sure of what those
different you know costs are it might be
different in for example in Nashville
than it is in Salem than it is in
Manchester I'm not entirely sure um I
can tell you uh that I do see a mix now
of flaggers and police officers uh I'm
not seeing as many police officers
anymore so it it seems to the system
that is currently going on seems to be
working um I would say I would say this
is probably more of a question for maybe
a police chief or something that has
some insight into what exactly they are
billing
if that I that answers your question
representa majori thank you Mr chairman
um two-part question but I may need to
throw a followup um are you familiar
with the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation Flagger and uniform
officer use and work Zone
guidelines I am familiar with it
to I know it exists do I know verbatim
no I do not may I ask a followup Mr
chairman absolutely so my question is
then in there and I don't expect you to
know it verbatim but in there it spells
out the guidelines for when a
municipality should use a flagger versus
when they should use a uniformed officer
do I understand you correctly that you
believe that that these guidelines based
on your experience are working well in
communities yes and um my understanding
also there too is uh and again the
latter half of my career was with uh
State Police so we dealt mostly with the
highways but in that particular case
that was the department of
transportation that was man mandating
you know whether or not there was a a
trooper that needed to be there or how
many Troopers needed to be there for
that particular uh package so there
there were guidelines that they followed
on that level and I know there are other
National guidelines that they follow
about with traffic vests and signage and
things of that nature that all follow
along
too representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the testimony uh are you
aware that uh there are many communities
in New Hampshire who have this issue if
there is an issue this item at least in
their
contract I do know that uh there are uh
several collective bargaining agreements
that speak to uh details and what I mean
by they speak to it um usually they
speak to such things as it allows the
police officer to uh put in for details
uh it may restrict the number of hours
that they can work it may speak to what
the actual detail rate is
uh you know for example in the Salem uh
Police contract it speaks to what 2024
what the 2024 rate is but it's the rate
for what the police officer receives not
necessarily what the town of Salem
receives I don't know if they have a SE
charge on top of that I know follow up
Mr chairman if I would go
ahead in the real world this is
lucrative uh money for the police uh
police police officer is it can we
justify the fact that we have an extra
police officer out at a site within the
town or city that you wouldn't normally
have and at a place where there's a
potential of some difficulty uh an
accident or whatever we have so thank
and would you also talk about the uh the
fact that the police officer has an
opportunity to make that extra
money makes it ends up having him at
least working in his his uh type of work
instead of going out and painting roofs
and that kind of stuff so is is there a
benefit to have that police officer and
is it worthwhile to have him on the site
yeah and thank you for the question um
you're absolutely right uh when you have
a an extra police officer there doing a
detail not only are they directing
traffic looking at traffic um they can
handle situations that occur right there
they can handle accidents that might
occur in the construction zone uh so
that it keeps another police officer
free to continue to do Patrol or answer
calls of that nature uh I know of
instances uh where uh they had uh bolos
be on the lookout for uh because
somebody had committed a crime and uh
they were now looking for either a
violent felon or something and the car
happens to travel into a construction
zone and they were able to apprehend the
person at the construction zone um so
there are those instances it also gives
the impression that there are more
police out on the street so even that
there's a even their presence there is a
a deterrent factor and to uh address
your last uh question it is it is a way
for police officers to make extra money
while they're still doing their same
function as a police officer instead of
having to you know paint roofs uh paint
houses do roofs or things of that nature
too thank you for your comments thank
you Mr chairman represent stavis thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question what are the unintended
consequences of this
legislature passing into law something
that could contradict or probably does
contradict the Department of
Transportation guidelines and the
long-established
practice of governing bodies of towns
and cities working closely with do along
those guidelines lines to make the
decisions on whether to have uniformed
officers or commercial flaggers there
thank you for the question I hope I can
answer your question um you know I think
if you're you're going to pass the
statute you do have to make sure that it
doesn't conflict with any um any
guidelines that the dot might have or
even federally uh although the federal
uh tends to be more on the
highway um so I think that's a concern
you have to look at um the the next
concern I I would have also with that
too is it may lead to
confusion uh and um there are instances
too
where you know let's face it there's
road rage out there people get angry
people get angry when they have to wait
in traffic people are in a hurry these
days um and when you have somebody
that's a flagger out there they don't
have the same Authority as a police
officer and what you may have in some of
these instances is some uh you know
chaos in these instances where a police
officer would prevented that or if road
rage were to occur the police officer
could address it right then and there
and uh not continue on so I I think
there are some benefits to having a
police officer doing doing construction
do I think every little piece of
construction needs to have a police
officer maybe maybe not I think it
depends on the situation and I think
that's why you leave it up to local
Chiefs to make that
determination forur the questions
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question let's just move away from the
money factor for a second do you think
that the workers and the people and the
guys doing these jobs are all safer when
we have law enforcement running these
details I thank you for the question and
yes I do think they are um you know I
think the uh and I know because I have
done some of these in the past when I
was younger um I can tell you right now
I wouldn't want to do it now um and the
only reason I say that is because I'm
older and it's not a lot of fun standing
in the street for 48 hours uh that being
said though when I did do it um the you
had a good relationship with the
companies that were there and um they
trusted you uh you looked out for them
you made sure that they were safe um and
again I I think that you know the
motoring public just respects a police
officer more than they do a flagger so
they're uh more willing to uh you know
obey the directions of a uh of a police
officer forther questions rep
representative
Gallagher uh so you were mentioning
about um police being able to be on the
lookout for things while they're
flaggers what sort of um Fourth
Amendment uh
protections um against search and
seizure do uh people have when uh police
are uh doing the these flagging details
so these would be um no different than
any other interaction that the police
would have with the with the motoring
public so if they're doing a detail here
all the still all the rules still apply
you need to have a you know articulable
suspicion and probable cause to make a
stop or to investigate something any
further um you know so it usually if
there's a bolo like for example that you
use that's because other officers
somewhere else have already done some
investigations they've come out with
their problem will cause they say we've
identified this subject that was driving
the vehicle uh this is the vehicle
they're driving this is the plate
they're driving uh or other identifying
factors uh and so if I see a car that's
similar to that you know but is maybe
maybe they don't have the plate number
but it it matches well I have
articulable suspicion to stop that
person maybe not arrest the person right
away but at least inquire as to whether
or not a crime is being committed or
they are the person that's being looked
after uh but but then from that point is
where a police officer would again just
normally build their probable cause and
if probable cause is built to the point
that an arrest needs to be made then
then that's what happens so the short
answer is they don't give up any any
rights you they're not losing anything
by having a detailed officer
there further questions representative
F thank you Mr chair um when a police
officer on traffic control duty is
tending to his police function
abolo whatever what happens to the
Traffic Control Function that he's there
for who does that yeah and that all
depends on the situation on what's
Happening sometimes uh there might be
multiple officers there where the one
officer can now take over both and and
and handle what needs to be done uh
there might be another instance where it
tempor temporarily has to be shut down
for a few minutes until another officer
can show up take over this particular
situ that that situation they were
dealing with so that they can get back
to um uh doing traffic control duties as
well too and and recently there's also
been instances where there are police
and traffic control flaggers working
together on these sites as well too so
uh the answer is is it wouldn't go
unattended it would be dealt with in a
in a way but it would all depend on you
know what are the facts in front of you
that you're dealing with at that
point yep representative Elward thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um absent the word shall in
this
amendment is it not enabling legislation
I mean is not the choices
optional well I guess now you know
looking at the proper Amendment it says
May so it does give you the option so
the shall is no longer there uh except
for a line uh nine which says the use of
uniformed officers shall only be
required no me yeah but that's a line
six if you go down to
line
oh maybe there's several amendments
there11 yeah I got it right
here okay so that was changeed to may as
well too um
and again I I think some of the concerns
I would still have is one um who makes
that decision is it the police chief is
a town counsel um you know where does
that uh decision made and two um again I
I don't know of any issues that we're
having now that we need to have a bill
that's put into into place and maybe I'm
just the wrong person to answer the
question I'm not sure but okay thank you
y further
questions seeing none I have a single
question for you sir sure um you
mentioned uh about officers having to
stand out in the street for 4 to eight
hours do all police details require the
officer to stand in the street or along
the street or can they be in their
vehicles it all depends on the situation
um if you're in a local town or a
specific sit uh you know where the
traffic is not on the highway so to
speak um you know there may be instances
uh most of the time where you're out
there and you're directing traffic and
you need to be physically out of your
car so I've had details where I've
actually been the traffic light where
I've stood in the middle of the the road
and I've had to stand there and it was
an 8 Hour detail and sure enough yeah
you switch off you have a break here and
there and you or you have lunch break
here and there and you work it out with
the other police officers that are there
uh so you have those instances I've also
had instances where I'm just in a lane
closure on a highway at which point it's
it's safe for everybody if I'm sitting
in the cruiser and just monitoring
traffic from there um so it all depends
I guess on what the specific
construction zone looks
like thank you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony I have one more
pink card I believe it's Dion Tad Dion
thank you everyone and uh have a good
afternoon make sure you turn on your
mic thank you sorry about that uh good
afternoon Mr chairman good afternoon
committee um I represent New Hampshire
Chiefs of police I am the chief of
police for Hudson New Hampshire we are
an accredited assoc we are an accredited
agency as well
nationally I sent you all a letter today
in opposition of this the chiefs of
police are in opposition of this bill
and I don't want to regurgitate what my
letter said but I'll take any questions
I do want to say uh before that that I
uh second everything all the unattended
consequences that attorney Bodwin so
eloquently spoke of I can tell you
personally in my career I have witnessed
the arrests of members of the public who
were motoring through a detail for one
reason or another um or from a bolo we
have had arrests of uh people of a d DUI
we've had arrests for people of theft
we've solved fraud cases from this uh a
few years ago we solved an armed bank
robbery because we had a detail officer
who heard the uh call go out over his
radio because they're all wearing a
radio he actually immediately moved
right to the bank cuz he was right in
front of it U I should say he was within
a quarter mile of it he went right to
the bank he stopped the um suspect from
getting into his getaway car and we
eventually located the subject and
arrested him for an nonbank robbery at
St Mary's bank but I'll take any
questions you might
have any
questions representative K thank you Mr
chair thanks for sharing those positive
actions that have happened um just out
of curiosity have you guys ever uh
stopped any amber alerts while doing a
detail
I cannot personally think of the time
when we actually stopped in Amber Alert
in Hudson New Hampshire um but certainly
we've we've stopped vehicles that were
involved in
aola for the questions representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question what Authority if
any does a commercial Flagger have to
stop or apprehend someone who's driving
erratically exhibiting road rage
committing a crime I know by Authority
they have uh or by Statute they have
authority to uh direct traffic they
don't have any other authority that I'm
aware of other than calling the
police um and actually having the police
investigate to do
that for the
questions seeing none I have one um so
far um similar to the last time we heard
uh testimony on this I've heard that
towns of naswa Salem Manchester you're
obviously from Hudson you represent the
New Hampshire Chiefs of police have you
spoken to any of the smaller communities
about this no I have not spoken to him
personally about it thank you forther
questions representa you
Kella thank you thank you for uh taking
the question um can
you have you when you were talking about
um this or if your experiences in Hudson
um is there a significant concern about
the
wages um is that a major topic of
conversation for municipalities uh or
the police officers in regard to
flagging um or is that um in your
experience a tangential issue um
thank you thank you uh good question I
could tell you the the wages that are
set in Hudson are set by a collective
bargaining agreement which includes
details um as far as administratively
obviously with the police officers we we
tell them how they're going to address
how they're going to work if you have a
complaint against police officer detail
you call it into us we'll handle it um
with regards to wages and pay I would
say I could tell you this we probably
there's a Highway Safety Committee in
Hudson that's how we handle it right
it's made up of the chief of police fire
chief Public Works director the engineer
from the town and planning and we
average probably 12 details a year where
we mandate a police detail we do we have
a lot more than 12 details a year um a
lot more so we're not we're not seeing
that we're you know we we have some
obviously that are uh not traffic
related right so those those are
different but um but just we we have so
many more details a year uh and they're
not they're not being mandated so the
vendor the contractor is actually
calling because they want a police
officer further
questions seeing uh represent
FR thank you Mr chair um I assume that
there is some sort of a training and
certification program for commercial
flaggers and if that is the
case do they have any advantage or
disadvantage in
their ability or skill set to control
traffic as compared to a certified
police officer that's a great question I
don't know I know they have a
certification I don't know what
encompasses I know our police officers
uh take the same training for the dot
the guidelines training that we were
talking about earlier that I think uh
you had mentioned representative um I
also know that our police officers are
trained at the Academy at basic traffic
control they're trained uh at our own
Police Department we do our field
training they're trained as well as that
um I don't know if there's any advantage
whatsoever I know the advantage the
police officers have is we have the
authority to stop a car that's acting
Reckless and we have the authority to
radio something in um and for for me
personally it is an extra resource it's
an extraordinarily extra resource to
have extra additional eyes and ears
presence that enhanced presence that
security that there because you have
extra officers that they're not within
your budget so to speak but they're
there because they're doing a road job
and they're in uniform and people know
their police
officers okay representative
McDonald uh thank you Mr chairman uh
Chief do PE police officers get heard on
these details at all I'm sorry do police
officers ever get heard on details
working details do they get hurt injured
get hurt they uh they may I'm support uh
I'm trying to think of whether or not
we've had an officer we've had officers
get hurt directing traffic but I'm not
sure if it was out of detail it might
have been out an accident um so
certainly they could yeah do you recall
probably about a year and a half ago a
state police sergeant that was killed on
a detail yes I do and was he work he was
working detail in the M Cruiser yes he
was thank
you further
questions CNN thank you very much I have
no more pink cards as I said we had uh
looks like 1 2 3 four seven people sign
in
opposed what's can
iog recognize yeah go
ahead but hold on hold on first I'm GNA
close
okay oh all right never
mind okay uh where's oh
okay representative
Manion thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record representative
Dennis Manion I represent Salem Rock 25
I'm here to speak in opposition of this
bill um the part I want to speak about
is line 10 which I I think we've some
people have discussed already
municipality it's not clear who's going
to make these decisions whether it's the
select
the Town Council the mayor or the police
chief or whatnot so I can tell you that
most details 90% of the details that are
filled are for like power companies or
tree companies and they usually filled
the night before so they'll call in and
say we need two offices for tomorrow and
that could be done there could be three
or four of those requests a night to be
filled for the next day they could start
at 67 or 8 in the morning so if we need
to convene the board of Selectmen every
evening
when someone calls in for a detail to
have them vote whether or not it's going
to be uh for a flagger or for police
offices that's going to take a lot of
time so I'm I'm talking and sometimes
like now cities like Nashua they could
have 20 or 30 of these details being
called in a night do we convene the
board of Selectmen every single time so
that they can vote as to whether or not
a police officer is required on this
thing I just I just think we should
leave it up to the police chief where
his authority uh lies in statute to
dictate the public safety of the town
and and leave it at
that thank you questions representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for representative for taking my
question do you know of any
other area of New Hampshire law that
requires a select board vote on whether
to employ uniformed officers in a
particular situation or not I'm not
aware of any law and statute that do
that thank
you forther questions representative
kahill thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Manion for coming to our
committee do you do you think that um
Chiefs of police know better safety
issues than the board of Selectmen when
when it comes to stuff like this 100%
that's why they're appointed is they the
they're in charge of Public Safety in
the
town further
questions representative Guthry thank
you Mr chair and I'll very quickly uh
I'm pretty sure the I know the answer
but do you I asked it earlier I think
that Salem has a contract their Union
they have a union for their police
officers you know how many uh cities and
towns have a
relationship uh union relationship with
a contract that covers this matter and
has been work working in in always been
never been a really a problem yeah as
far as the the union and the contract uh
writing which would be the board of
Select yes so I would say most towns do
I know uh in my experience I worked in
law enforcement for many years and every
town that I worked for had a contract um
that governed
details thank you thank you Mr J
questions rep I'm sorry that's all right
represent McDonald I don't know if you
can answer this for me not but as I
recall there there's an hours say that
doesn't allow the selectman to tell the
chief how to run his Department would
this conflict with that it would the
police the police there is a statute
that says the police chief has authority
over Public Safety in any town or city
any representative FR thank you uh
representative I don't know if you know
the answer to this or not but um can you
inform us the relative difference in
cost to say a tree contractor or a
Paving Company to hire a uniformed
officer versus a certified and trained
Flagger I do not know the cost um
difference however I could say on times
I have worked with flaggers I've seen
them throw signs on on hoods of cars
I've heard them talking about women
driving by on their radios and I've seen
some of them had that have had a
warrants and they've been arrested on
the job that's been my
experience for the questions
representative Elward you look like you
yes thank you I just want to clarify
you're saying that um flaggers are not
required to pass a criminal background
check I'm not aware of that if they are
or not but whether they have a criminal
background Checker not doesn't they can
have a warrant for something but not
have a criminal history so it wouldn't
come up I understand thank you further
questions seeing none I have a single
question for your representative uh you
seem to imply
that each time
flaggers or uniform police officers
would need to be used that they would
require a vote of the Selectmen where
that was a scenario because in line 10
municipality is not defined does that
mean the board of Selectmen and if a
detail comes in at 10:00 at night for
the next day for Liberty Utilities do
they have to decide whether a police
officer is used or not or does the
supervisor on duty to decide that that
was my
scenario correct but is it your belief
that a vote would be required for each
time a police detail is required
it certainly could be interpreted that
way thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony I don't believe
we have any more pin cards or do we we
done with this one I have no more than
uh we'll go ahead and close the hearing
on oh did you still want to acknowledge
some let me close it first uh close the
hearing on HB 1053 somebody don't move
cuz
[Music]
representative m rald our clerk would
like to say
something thank you Mr chairman I just
want to uh recognize uh Chief Goldstein
I went to the academy the police academy
with him in 1980 and he's still in
police
work thank you Mr chair absolutely okay
we're going to get right into our next
one because we're about uh half hour
behind so
we
ask so we're going to go ahead and open
up the hearing on HB
1053 relative to permissible residential
units in a commercial
Zone I believe that is representative
Murray Prime
sponsor the floor is yours ma'am thank
you Mr chair and thank you honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is alisandra Murray I represent
uh Hillsboro District 20 which is
Manchester Ward
9 um so the bill before you today is uh
House Bill 1053 and I've also passed
around an amendment that just makes a
couple um edits to the language but
doesn't change
um any major content in the bill uh this
bill seeks to address our current
housing crisis by allowing for the
creation of residential and mixed
residential units within any commercial
lot whether that be new construction or
Rehabilitation of existing structures so
this bill ensures that these units would
be restricted by exist existing local
guidelines for commercial structures
regarding lot Dimension and coverage as
well as building high standards and
while in this legislature we often defer
to local control our housing crisis has
reached a level where we cannot wait for
changes to be made incrementally on the
local level we need broad sweeping
zoning reforms that can start to solve
this crisis
now according to the 2023 annual
homelessness assessment report from the
US Department of Housing and Urban
Development homelessness Rose in New
Hampshire by 52% which was in the last
year which was the highest increase in
the nation surpassing New Mexico New
York and
Colorado according to the New Hampshire
real Association the median cost for
home purchases has increased every
single year since 1998 and the median
cost in New Hampshire is now at 470,000
which is a 7% increase in cost from just
a year ago according to Redfin a
national real estate uh brokerage nearly
a third of all home purchases in the
state of New Hampshire in 2022 were cash
only indicating a clear wealth Gap and
who can actually afford to purchase a
home at this time then meanwhile
according to New Hampshire housing rent
in the State increased by 11% in just
the last year from my own experience I
can tell you that when my husband and I
rented our first apartment together it
was a 2 half bedroom for $900 a month
and when we left 5 years later it was
$1,600 without any Inc uh Renovations or
improvements being done on the property
so the data here is clear the housing
crisis is not showing any signs of
slowing down and especially not New
Hampshire and granite Staters are
suffering for it we need to take radical
action now to stop this problem getting
even worse zoning reforms such as those
proposed in this bill are an integral
part of solving the housing crisis and
encouraging new construction which
according to the US Commerce department
has significantly slowed in New
Hampshire and bringing residential units
into commercial zones is not only a way
to expand the area for potential
building but also encourages the kind of
building that young people especially
want to live in if we mix commercial and
residential zones we lower the need for
parking minimums encourage walkability
and create the kind of communities our
state need to thrive um so I'd be happy
to answer any questions on the bill but
it's pretty simple just allowing for
residential building within commercial
Lots across the state um and I did work
with um Folks at New Hampshire Housing
and a couple other organizations to um
draft this bill but
yeah thank you uh representative
major thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for testifying so I'm just curious
it says that um in any City town or
county in which there are located
unincorporated towns or unincorporated
places so it's only in those areas that
have
unincorporated places do do I understand
that correctly I believe so yeah okay
thank
you further
questions representative
Gallagher
um was so I'm um looking at the
amendment and um the original Bill side
by side here and um I'm not really quite
sure I'm spotting the differences
between the two properly so you could
you go into a bit more detail about um
what exactly the how exactly the
amendment differs from the original bill
um and why um it honestly is mainly just
an effort to make the language a little
bit um clearer and it didn't really
change too much in terms of like the
actual content of the bill but just
trying to make sure that um the statute
was written in as um detailed way as
possible while also leaving what we
needed to up to local zoning
ordinances representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um and and thank
you for answering the previous question
but I didn't really feel like I got an
answer sure um if if you could kindly
just go through the amendment
and show us exactly what is different
there than the original that would be
really helpful sure um I think um the
biggest differences are I included shall
allow residential and mixed residential
uses instead of I believe the original
build had just
residential um and included the line
around lot coverage and height standards
being no more restrictive than those
required for commercial
structures um added the line
um and 10 that shall not require or
sorry not 10
um uh well there was a line added around
shall not require more than one space
per dwelling unit when it comes to the
uh parking requirements so that's line
seven actually um and then uh the last
line is a new line
representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your testimony representative
uh I I think it's a great idea I'm hope
I'm quite sure it probably came out of
housing but the housing committee
somehow or other uh but I have a real
problem with matter of
right
uh I'm a selectman in the town and I
have a hard time going back to my
constituents and say the head of my
planning board and said hey he
this was a good idea but not only is it
a good idea you got to do it so could
you talk a little bit why you the board
I mean the the bill says matter of right
instead of just leaving it out as a
May well I mean it says it because OS
wrote it that way um I didn't ask for
you know the matter of right to be put
in there but I think the reason why that
language is there is to clarify that
this is an intention to change zoning um
ordinances like in a Statewide manner
instead of District by district and so I
think that might be why the language is
put that way um which I think is
necessary at this stage because of how
bad the housing crisis has gotten here
in particular that um doing incremental
change Community by Community is just
not happening in a way that's fast
enough to address the
issue thank you for your answer thank
you Mr chairman repres representative
PRI
thank you Mr chairman for and thank you
for taking my question um in your
Amendment you talk about the
unincorporated towns and unorganized
places how many are
there do you know that this bill would
apply to and has an inventory of the
vacant commercial space that meets these
parameters have also been identified
um thank you for your question um to the
first part I would say that was um
something suggested uh to me that I add
by um someone who works in housing and
is uh well aware of like the zoning
ordinances across the state um so I
myself do not know very much about um
you know unincorporated towns or
unorganized places and I'm not sure if
there has been an assessment done um in
terms of the amount of vacant commercial
lots that would be um
you know covered by this bill although I
would be happy to look into that and
send anything I find to the
committee representative
kill thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and good to see you
again um so you know I I I'm thinking in
terms of like my commercial District in
my town and you know I know where
there's some some Lots but I they're
next to a rock quy that does blasting
and I if if you give a matter of right
that some someone can build residential
use in that kind of a commercial
District do you see that as something
that we should do like in that
example I mean I personally would argue
that in this kind of Market we need
housing of all kinds and people can make
the choice for themselves whether they
want to live near a blasting zone or not
representative
fra thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
I have a concern on the density
requirement um I can conceive of a
situation where the land will not
support the prescribed density
requirement because of say Wetland or
ledge and the density would have to be
VAR
from your requirement I'm wondering if
perhaps some different language um might
be more
appropriate you're talking about that
last
line I'm referring to the last four
lines um starting with the the
jurisdiction shall not require a lower
density than one unit per two
acres uh with on-site well or sewage Etc
um you know if the committee I think you
all probably know a lot more on this
subject than I do and if you found it
appropriate to make an amendment you
know I would be supportive of that but I
do think that like I said I talked with
some experts in the field on this
language and this was what they
suggested
so thank you representative
yella hi thank you thank you for taking
the question um are you wedded to this
um language uh online for that says in
which there are located unincorporated
towns and un Incorporated P places if
that language was not there um would you
still be in favor
of this yes thank
you representative hi thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question I appreciate the work you've
done to be creative um to solve the
housing crisis I I question the experts
who talk talk to um were they all
housing um Advocates looking to increase
the housing
Supply um and did that include
developers in those
experts um I didn't speak to any
developers although I will say my mom is
a real estate agent and I've picked up a
lot of information from her and her work
um I generally spoke with people who are
examining uh the zoning in the state and
how much that is impacting our current
housing crisis and like I said the um US
Department of Commerce has noted that
construction new construction in the
state has gone down significantly so um
I worked with people who are interested
in removing barriers to new construction
and like you said coming up with
Creative Solutions because I I'm in
Manchester you know there's not a lot of
undeveloped land so what else can we do
to create more
housing further questions representative
priest you turn your mic M your m than
you now for the questions I have a
single question for you since you
mentioned
Manchester do the current zoning
regulations in
Manchester uh
allow at least in some places the
residential to be on a commercial lot
yes it's some places thank you further
questions representative stus thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking yet
another question so
um I'm in Lebanon which is a fairly
good-sized City there are a lot of
residential units on top of or amongst
commercial
properties um that is
allowable so I'm I'm
wondering why isn't that happening now
why is this bill necessary is it the by
right part of the bill that you believe
is the necessary part or is is there
something else because this is already
happening in many of our communities
yeah I think that that is the intention
you know that it can happen but it is
not always happening in every situation
that it can happen you I guess I know
that it wasn't um the most popular bill
but hb44 from last year the way like
that was attempting to address zoning in
a Statewide manner instead of community
by Community is kind of how this bill is
functioning as well follow up thank you
Mr chair thank you again do you know of
any communities where um residential and
Commercial are
banned um not off the top of my head now
thank
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you for your testimony we've got uh
looks like four pink cards I'm just
going to go down the list
here Ben kemer
I'll remind everybody when you uh sit
down please uh state your name who
you're here representing and whether
you're for or against thank you good
afternoon um thank you for hearing my
testimony my name is Ben Kramer I live
in New Market um I'm supporting HB
1053 um I represent New Hampshire youth
movement I'm organizing director at New
Hampshire youth movement um that is an
organization with a base of over 100
dedicated members and more than 5,000
supporters ages 15 to 30 across the
state of New Hampshire um I'm here to
speak on behalf of young Granite Staters
and as a young renter myself um as I
testify in support of this bill um I I
think the main thing with this bill is
there there's this
striking statistic that we need to build
20,000 units in two years to keep up
with demand in the state we have a major
housing shortage and that is a very very
large number and this bill takes an
important step towards meeting that goal
and making this a state wherever one has
a home and where people can stay um the
housing shortage is is a major issue for
all Granite Staters but young people in
particular um this is there's a direct
correlation between how many young
people stay in the States and how easy
it is to find suitable affordable
housing young people like myself and my
members we want to stay in New Hampshire
but we simply cannot if we cannot find a
suitable place to live um I I think the
strength of this bill is fundamentally
it's about cutting red tape and opening
the door to the development of Housing
close to where people work and where
people recreate um especially in New
Hampshire's major cities commercial
areas are where people want to be it's
where their jobs are it's where they
grocery shop it's where they grab dinner
with friends um and especially recently
we've seen major parts of these
commercial zones become underutilized
due to shifts and you know how we work
and do business um and that leaves
office spaces industrial parks with a
lot of usable space that might be
sitting empty in places across the state
um and I I think that we need to
recognize that there's a perfect match
here and an opportunity here um and cut
the red tape to allow these disused but
desirable spaces to be turned into the
housing we desperately need um it's a
big gap that we have to close I like I I
cannot emphasize that enough and I think
representative Murray did a good job of
emphasizing that as well um this is a
creative solution I think we need all
the Creative Solutions at our disposal
um to meet the scale of this problem uh
yeah I would urge the community to
support this bill um and takes a step
towards New Hampshire a place where
everyone has a home they deserve and
where young people can make a future for
themselves it's important I'm happy to
take any questions representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so um my
question is with regards to the
application of this if it were to become
law does would this look like um a
development where would be live work
play or recreate type of developments
that we see would or or
is or would it be just like a
one unit that somebody might choose to
construct within a commercial
Zone what would that what would this
look like yeah I I mean I'm I'm not a
developer I'm not a someone who would be
you know going out and building units
because of this bill um I'm here to you
know support the the opportunity I see I
think that that's like a a decisions
that are ultimately going to be made by
the people who are envisioning the pro
the projects that would be possible
under this bill um I think in general
you know opening the door for Living
Solutions like that is is what we need
um with the problem that we face now
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here taking
the question could when you respond
could you remind me of your
organization um my question is and I was
going to ask a representative this but I
saved it for you um
do you think that this legislation
will take the burden off of larger
municipalities cities um and share it
more with the other municipalities
around the state in smaller
towns I see what you're saying um the
the organization is New Hampshire youth
movement um to the first part of your
question um and I I think if I
understand your question correctly
I would say yes and I think that's part
of the appeal here is this opens the
door
to to to not have you know every person
just looking for where is rent on
average the cheapest we're going to
flock there and to be able to to build
in more cities to be able to build up
more desirable communities that people
want to move to to to lower rent in
other places and and have more options
than other places I I think that is if I
understand what you mean by like
spreading the burden out um I think that
is a part of the appeal of this bill um
yeah representative kill thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
do you so do you see this as a tool to
um take like say an abandoned commercial
project or something that's been bacon
for a long time and but as a matter of
right then maybe turned it into
Apartments is that is that what the goal
of this type yeah I I mean again I'm not
a I'm not a housing expert or policy
zoning expert but I think that would be
a a part of the the vision of the things
I think that we need to do in the state
to meet the the level of the this huge
gap that we have to fill is what exactly
what you just described looking at
disused and underutilized spaces and and
how can we make those places where
people can live and have a decent home
um
yeah representative uh
F thank you Mr chair um in my town of
Enfield we we had a case where a
apartment well where a uh building owner
who had
commercial uh retail or office space
found it more attractive from a
financial point of view to break that up
and rent it out as
Apartments is um shall I call it
deterioration of a commercial District a
possible unintended consequence of this
bill um could could you repeat the last
part of that question I'm not sure I
understand okay um my question is um if
a the owner of a commercial property
decided that it was
more economically attractive to him or
her to discont continue the commercial
use of the building and convert it into
housing that would eliminate some
commercial space in town which might
have been the hardware store or a
restaurant or whatever I see what you're
saying do you see do you see this bill
as possibly opening up a Pandora's box
of unintended
consequences well I I think what I would
say in that scenario is that the the
incentives are the incentives and the
you know what is going to be the most
profitable for the owner of that space
is is going to remain unchanged um
whether or not you know they there
exists a bunch of red tape for them
changing it or or not um and I
think the you know those are decisions
that ultimately property owners are
going to make whether or not regardless
of the the specifics of the zoning in
the state um or in their particular
and I think um you know
prioritizing the the obvious need that
we have in the state is for houses for
people um I think that problem exists
regardless that problem exists no matter
what we do um and I think that is a is a
very strong incentive and it's something
that worth prioritizing you know people
need houses in the states yeah thank you
for the question
we thank you thank you for taking the
question um
in the past there has been a sentiment
that commercial activities should be
over on this part of town and
residential should be over here and it
should be segregated and you and this
has led to like you know you you stay in
one part of town and you have to drive
all the way across town to go to work
and then drive to go get your groceries
and stuff like that um since you
represent a lot of young people do you
think that that sentiment of like it
should be in different parts of the town
or the city or the state um has is kind
of antiquated and now um actually the
the people young people like you
represent actually would prefer their
prop their location their habitation to
be in very short uh you know proximity
to where they work and where they uh
shop yeah I I think that is desirable
for a lot of people um and especially
you know folks myself and young people
um I think the you I don't think anyone
likes you know a long commute to work um
I I would say too that the the need to
have anywhere suitable to live is
overriding you know is is immense um for
people in the states and I think that is
like an extra it is it is a bonus of
like this creates particularly desirable
housing and it creates like young people
cannot find houses in general you know
within hours of their work um so I think
that is a deep need as well yeah
represent priest sorry uh thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
being here do you really believe that
young people are going to live in
abandoned commercial areas in
unincorporated towns and unorganized
places and drive hours to their places
of work in Manchester the Sea Coast and
and other
environments yeah well I I think under
this bill the whole point is that those
those places would no longer be
abandoned they would be able to be
revitalized and turned into suitable
homes for people um and I think that's a
it's a vision worth supporting is is
using underutilize and disuse space like
you described as um bringing breathing
new life into it um and I think that
that that is the the opportunity I see
in this bill and I think that that is a
a vision that I know my membership young
people in the state certainly support
yeah representative St uh go ahead
representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking another question so I'm
sitting here feeling a little
embarrassed because I'm searching my
memory banks and I'm Googling and I'm
looking and looking looking to see where
New Hampshire law actually prevents this
from
happening and I'm wanting to ask you can
you cite chapter in verse of where this
is actually forbidden to happen because
it's certainly happening in my city all
over the place um there's tons and tons
of Residential Properties going up over
retail establishments so I'm just trying
to find
out you know what what is the what is
the need here because because
that activity is not being allowed and
that's what I'm coming up short on and
as I say I'm embarrassed that I can't
find that I I do not know off the top of
my head like I said I'm not a I'm not a
zoning policy expert um I know there's
other experts in the room and and
perhaps they might be able to speak to
that um I think that this this
bill ensures that that is not the case
um and I think that that is part of the
appeal
th this bill ensures that that is not
the case um I I think that is a that's
assurance that we need with a scale of
of the problem that we have we need to
build 20,000 units in in two years you
know I think we need to um to have all
the assurance that we can that is
possible throughout this state
representative
lales yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question as I read
this I'm not sure what this bill applies
to
because it
says
um of any City town or county in which
there are
unincorporated towns or un organized
places now I don't
know what areas of the State of New
Hampshire have those because that's the
only ones that it seems that they
applies to but more specifically I I've
got a A for
instance
uh I know a lot of us know where Brown
Avenue is in
Manchester if as you come off
293 and you're going toward the airport
down Brown Avenue what do you find it's
mainly a a commercial area but you have
gas station that have been abandoned for
decades that are on that street you have
other commercial areas that are
abandoned on that you have boarded up
houses this
is and I don't know why this is maybe
there's something there that I don't
understand but as you're reading this
would that be an area that would be
applicable for this do you know the area
I'm talking about Brown Avenue no I I
don't personally I think I'm if I'm
understanding your question right you
have a question about the the language
is the is the first thing and then the
the the specific scenario is the second
thing I think to to the language as I
read this I I interpret this as City
town or county in which there's
unincorporated towns or unorganized
places as three distinct and separate
categories um I don't know what the
grammar term would would would be for
that but as three I don't know if
Clauses is the right term but you know
three distinct um situations in which
this would apply
um okay and and I would I would leave
that to to to perhaps the bill sponsor
to to clarify that language if that's
necessary I'd like to ask representative
priest to go offline with me and explain
that to me on Brown no no no no we don't
oh that was a okay gotcha
representative question thank you um
perhaps to clarify the
language if you remove the comma after
City on line four and inserted the word
or so it reads legislative body of a
city or town or County or perhaps or a
county in which there are located un
incorp at towns would that help clarify
the
language okay we'll
get let's not get
into edits
or I I believe the intent of this bill
is to have those three things as
distinct categories not to strictly
apply to just unincorporated towns and
unorganized places so I think it's a
language change it should be addressed
if it needs to
further
questions representative lales could you
flick off that mic for me please
oh uh seeing none um I I just have one
you said you from New Market yes does do
the zoning
uh regulations in New Market already
allow residential units on a commercial
lot I'm not sure um yeah like I said not
not a policy expert I think if they if
they don't already they ought to um as
is the case with uh communities across
the
state thank you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
committee members uh Ben Frost deputy
director and chief legal officer for New
Hampshire housing uh here to speak in
support of uh House Bill
1053 um I before I talk about um the
comments I had in mind I do want to
address the some confusion over this uh
text bridging lines three and four where
it says
um legislative body of a city town or
county in which there are located
unincorporated towns or unorganized
places
um this is if if you
change um nothing in this this this
amendment let that be it because this is
a turn of phrase that occurs innumerable
times in the Planning and Zoning
statutes and I think you would have a um
knockdown drag out with u the um
drafting Attorneys at OLS because that
is a phrase and prior speaker is correct
in in noting that this is um three
distinct things
cities towns and a county in which there
are these unincorporated places
specifically that's referring to Kos
County uh which uh has a County planning
board that has a planning Administration
over the unincorporated places in Coos
County uh so that's what is intended by
uh that phrase to the uh the substance
of the legislation um representative
yella earlier talked about the the
separation of uses and this really goes
back to the origins of zoning um in the
1920s
really uh when the US Department of
Commerce promulgated a standard State
zoning enabling act uh and that became
the model for uh Most states to
establish uh their zoning enabling acts
New Hampshire included uh the the final
model was uh put out by the Department
of Commerce in 1926 New Hampshire
actually adop based its zoning enabling
act on a slightly earlier version 1925
but the the differences are not Material
here uh so since that time New Hampshire
has enabled its municipalities to adopt
zoning and included in that idea is the
separation of incompatible uses this is
what we know as ukian zoning uh ukian
being a reference to a US Supreme Court
case uclid uh Amer realy versus uid Ohio
uh which upheld a
municipality's uh police Power Authority
to engage in zoning the separation of
so-called incompatible uses so this is
something we've acknowledged uh for a
long time almost 100 years now uh as uh
being within a municipal capacity or in
New Hampshire as we a Dyan rule state
not a home rule state a state power that
is delegated to municipalities
um but the issue of of separation of
uses is something that you might say uh
just because you can do it doesn't
necessarily mean it is in all instances
a good idea uh and this is something
that over the years especially recently
uh we have begun to discover that uh the
uh holding hard and fast to separation
of uses is not necessarily a good thing
uh and we discovered this
uh here in New Hampshire well one of the
discoveries was with Municipal
implementation of the workforce housing
law which was adopted by the legislature
in 2008 and some communities said okay
we'll do what we have to but we're going
to relegate the workforce housing to
these commercial zones over there and to
uh their surprise perhaps not to
everyone's surprise it actually worked
so you have these residential uses being
built in commercial zones and uh they
are not in fact incompatible uh they do
in fact uh mutually support each other
so having people living in commercial
commercial areas I won't call them
commercial zones but commercial areas
provides eyes on the street security at
night people being there around uh what
would otherwise be um unsecured uh
commercial spaces having activity of
people living approximate to commercial
uses actually supports the commercial
uses uh people who are living closer to
those commercial entities are more
likely to frequent them because they're
there uh so this is something that we
have come to realize that we took this
idea of separation of uses uh way too
far and this legislation seeks to make a
partial correction to that I'll note
just in closing um I I won't name the
town but I'll recount account and
experience I had with u a planning board
that I was on at the time and there was
a proposal for a residential use it was
tow houses right up next to a state
highway a busy State Highway a lot of
Highway noise yes um and another board
member asked the question well well who
would want to live
there and I felt like answering probably
someone who could not afford for your
big house but for whom this would be
affordable and we can deal with the
sound uh these are places that are
suitable for residential use uh and by
the way also generate tax revenue for
municipalities I'd be happy to take any
questions representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I'll I'll ask
you the same question and I think you
know perhaps people might be having
difficulty imagining what the
application of this this bill might look
like can you point to anything that any
type of a such development that that
would help us to um imagine or picture
what this um what this would look like
could it be like an abandoned mall where
some apartments might be um put in with
a grocery store a movie theater a
dentist a hair salon Etc I know that
I've traveled to Connecticut and I've
seen these these new like developments I
think that they might be called um live
work play they're like old um fashion
like downtown centers where you know
there's businesses and and there's um
you know apartments and um Services
could you comment on that I'd be happy
to and thank you for that question
representative power um a couple of
examples um here in New Hampshire uh one
is Woodmont Commons and London Dairy the
the extraordinarily large development uh
probably the largest development um in
well at the time it was it was being
built uh in in New Hampshire I'd say
Tuscan Village is probably larger now um
but that's a a mix of uses so that
that's new development uh that is a mix
of uses and it's built upon yes live
work play or lifestyle uh centers or
things like that these are these are
sorts of developments that are going up
all over the place uh here in conquered
uh plans for the um partial Demolition
and reconstruction of the area of the
the Steeplegate Mall is going to be both
residential and Commercial um and and
those are those are fairly those are
large scale examples but I think if you
walk through uh any of your
downtowns and just stop and look at the
buildings in in the center of the
village or the center of the city uh and
look at at the building on the street
level commercial and then turn your gaze
upward and you'll see offices and
residential uses too mixes of uses uh
certainly appropriate for conversions of
abandoned or derel structures as well
representative sa thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so this
is happening in New Hampshire the kind
of development this bill
envisions where is the RSA that prevents
it from happening that this attempts to
solve that is an excellent question
representative stavis and there is no
RSA that prevents it from happening uh
this bill compels it to
happen representative
yella thank you thank you for uh taking
the question um I keep on hearing this
refrain about where is where uh is this
going to happen can you um kind of put
on a different hat and maybe uh talk a
little bit about the housing map and if
this might be uh or the zoning map that
you worked on uh and if or zoning Atlas
sorry um and if this type
of um barring by
municipalities um might be able to be uh
uh assessed in that zoning
Atlas that's a great question
representative yella and just as a point
of reference um uh representative is
referring to the New Hampshire zoning
Atlas you can Google that and check it
out yourselves it is a tremendously
powerful resource for anyone to use um
in the in building the the data behind
the zoning Atlas uh which
includes something on the order of
400,000 data entries um we had to make
certain assumptions and certain
generalizations so we did look at zones
that are primarily residential zones
that are primarily commercial I think it
is it it is possible to do that sort of
analysis but it would would require
someone to go into the data pretty deep
uh and and parse things out but I think
it's possible but uh it would require a
lot of interns
probably for the questions
representative
Gallagher um
so in online planning circles um there's
this meme where people will um put a
caption saying um this sort this kind of
smart walkable mixed use urbanism is
illegal to build in most American cities
um so this kind of um jumping off of rep
power's question so would you agree that
basically um any image that and um
urbanist has bothered to apply that
caption 2 online would be an example of
um what uh this is this is trying to
um or require to be allowed by
right yes representative gallager I I
think that's a great way of putting it
um and and this is consistent
with um past observations
of our our love for our
Villages uh our historic V Villages and
our acknowledgement that uh the the
zoning in which those Villages are
situated would not allow those villages
to be built today uh and that includes
the mix of commercial and residential
uses which is historically appropriate
uh so in in many communities you can't
do the things that we say we
love for the
questions seeing N I have one for you Mr
Frost this is going to be further known
as representative turkot question a that
way I don't have to repeat it time and
time
again can municipalities already
accomplish what this bill is attempting
to force or compel as you use the word
um see none appreciate your testimony
uh next up Nate Grace
nhma thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association uh we oppose this
legislation we we do oppose all
Statewide land use
mandates um I did write a letter um that
I uploaded to the website um so you have
that um I'm looking at the amendment
right now and it is is quite broad
um it seems the applic a would be to
attempt to require things that
municipalities already do which you can
see if you look out the window behind
you um because we of course are in
downtown conquered where we have mixed
residential and commercial use um and we
have developments that we've listed tus
and Village Etc that that they're doing
this already um in the interest of
hopefully improving the situation with
housing um in my letter I did suggest a
potential place all Amendment which was
to look at Senate Bill 538 take a couple
of sections from there um relative to
79e um the community community
revitalization tax um relief incentive
this is uh a program or a policy put in
place by the legislature back in 2006
it's been expanded several times um and
what it does is it helps municipalities
that are in interested in dealing with
some of the abandoned properties that
they see uh figure out how to make that
economically viable for
developers um so what the sections I
suggested that you might consider taking
from Senate Bill 538 are is that it
would expand that option um to include
commercial properties you could also
include industrial properties um as well
as others and the way this may work is
we've
seen not so much in New Hampshire
because we're we're the state where they
all come but we've seen in larger cities
um some of the commercial uses uh
decrease as people have been working
more from home um or changing uses so
one of the questions is well what do we
do with those properties if they're no
longer viable as commercial uses are
there incentives we could put in place
to help developers redevelop those um
that's really the Genesis behind that
section of that legislation um that may
assist because it would provide a local
option to provide local incentives to
help development occur in already
existing buildings um and I think that's
a very targeted approach that may be
helpful I'm certainly happy to take any
questions the Comm may
have representative y Kell thank you I I
uh applaud your trying to to to switch
this um stick into a carrot uh for
municipalities however
um for those um are you aware of
municipalities um that that the
representatives continually ask are bar
like you you give examples of of of
conquer and Salem and you know do and
those places H allow this type of of
um uh building and so they would not
actually be um negatively impacted by
this legislation only municipalities
like mine that choose to Bar um uh
residential from those those uh
commercial spaces so are you aware of
those and and did you specifically um uh
reach out to those those uh
towns and cities that already do allow
this and were they in opposition to
other municipalities taking on that
burden also and and not just having to
shoulder them themselves or did you not
did you just base your comments on the
the nhma
principles I believe your question is
whether I surveyed members as to their
position on housing
on on this
specific thing that they some some
municipalities already allow this and
this is requiring the other
municipalities that don't already allow
this and if they are in favor of those
other municipalities doing the same
thing that they are doing or if they are
are intended to shoulder that entire
burden themselves or if you based your
opposition on the actual n nhma um
zoning Statewide
zoning uh principle instead of actually
talking with the with the um members
individually well thank you for the
question representative yella um uh back
uh a couple years ago uh we did have a
policy setting conference that I believe
certain members of this committee served
on and one of the Committees was uh
talked about housing extensively and one
of the topics that came up was
um what if anything should we do in
response to some of the some of the
information coming forward about housing
shortages um and there was a pretty
in-depth conversation about um housing
and the role of of municipalities um in
that um and after a robust debate U by
the members representing their
municipalities there um that committee
recommended some changes um to our
policies which then went to our our full
body that voted on them so the vast
majority of our members present in
voting are in support of our existing
policy to oppose Statewide land use
mandates although I believe there were a
few denters among
[Music]
those representative PRI thank you for
taking my question and and thank you for
being here
um with this propos Al I mean I I come
from the city of Manchester who has been
doing this
practice for over 20 years and I know
that other cities are doing the same
thing the issue that I have a concern
about is those commercial areas that are
not appropriate for residential
uses and with this legislation you're
mandating communities to put residential
in these areas that may not be
appropriate for Human
Habitat I agree
completely for the questions seeing none
thank you very much thank you final pin
card I know you've been waiting there
Grace Murray you are up
um hello um I my name is Grace
Murray um and I am from Amherst New
Hampshire and I represent New Hampshire
youth
movement um as a young New Hampshire
resident uh and a lifelong New Hampshire
resident I'm extremely concerned about
our housing uh our house crisis and in
strong support of uh HB
1053 as a resident of New Hampshire I've
experienced housing and security
multiple times throughout my childhood
and young adulthood and that is an issue
that a lot of young people face in our
state there's just not enough housing
for all of us in fact I think as
previously uh previously mentioned um a
report from NH housing shows that we
need 20,000 more uh units in the next
two years to accommodate our growth on
top of that thousands of grite State ERS
are struggling to pay their property
taxes buy a home pay their rent or find
a place to live at
all allowing housing to be built in
commercial areas is just one important
step toward addressing this crisis
passing HB 1053 would make it easier for
developers to build housing and it
promotes efficient land use and
infrastructure these are things that we
need this bill doesn't just affect the
amount of housing available though it
would also have a a positive impact in
the municipalities themselves mixed use
housing andc encourages investment in
local businesses reduces traffic
congestion um and it builds a sense of
community another Pro with this
legislation is people could be closer to
their jobs many young people struggle
with finding reliable transportation and
that is a huge barrier to finding
employment this bill also addresses this
issue transportation is no longer an
issue if your job is within walking
distance of your
home also to address some questions that
have come up um I don't think the point
of this bill is that it's currently
against law but rather it removes the
red tape on the municipal level that
hinders uh new construction by requiring
multiple layers of
approval to summarize this bill tackles
a myriad of issues Granite Staters are
are facing simply by allowing developers
to build housing and empty buildings and
land the housing crisis in New Hampshire
is dire I urge you to take a step
forward to a step towards fixing this
crisis and support HB
1053 thank you for your time and
consideration and I'll take any
questions thank you very much do we have
questions you lucked out I think we're
questioned out questioned
out very good thank you for your
testimony thank you very
much okay with that uh that was the last
pin card I have so that closes the
hearing on
HB 1053
all right folks we are down to the last
one of the
day everybody good to go looks good all
right we'll open up the hearing on HB
1175 relative to official ballot
referendum form of town meetings
representative power is the prime and
she is here to speak representative
power your floor
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as a prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill
1175 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason in Greenville in
Hillsboro County District 36 to begin
this bill was filed upon the request of
numerous
constituents as well as Citizens this is
a simple straight forward Bill the
purpose of this bill is to amend the
method to adopt the official ballot
referendum form of town meeting commonly
known and referred to
asb2 in 1995 when SP2 became law almost
30 years ago the legislature in its
wisdom placed the question to adopt sb2
on the official ballot this meant that
voters were able to vote on the question
to adopt sb2 at the poll on Election Day
additionally according to information
that I obtained from the Dr website as
of December 2019 152 political
subdivisions have adopted theb2 form of
meeting that is 71 towns and 81 school
districts now in 2019 a bill was signed
into law which removed the question to
adopt sb2 from the official ballot and
instead required that the question to
adopt was to be voted on at the
traditional town meeting or School
District meeting since the law was
changed beginning in 2020 there have
been a total of 32 Warren articles
proposed to adopt
sb2 31 of those proposals have failed
and only one proposal resulted in the
adoption of SP2 and that was Nottingham
in
2020 additionally to date I have found
12 municipalities and Counting because
not all warrants have been posted to the
um
internet so I found 12 municipalities
that have SP2 adoptions on their 2024
warrants which will be voted upon at the
upcoming um annual meetings typically
held in March Mr chairman it is clear to
me that SP2 has been handcuffed by the
unnecessary change in statute that was
made in
2019 I find this to be a serious problem
that must be addressed by the
legislature and that's why I filed this
bill before you House Bill 1175 simply
places the question to adopt s SP2 back
onto the official ballot enabling voters
to vote on the question to adopt sb2 at
the polls instead of the traditional
town meeting as the legislature deemed
appropriate 30 years
ago moreover this bill undoes
inequitable standards caused by the 2019
um bill and the subsequent change in the
law inexplicably the 2019 Bill kept the
question to resend SP SP2 on the
official ballot while moving the
question to
adopt SP2 to the traditional town
meeting that's where it voted upon
this doesn't make any sense by placing
the question to adopt SP2 back onto the
official ballot the method to adopt SP2
is the same as the method to resend
finally a few important things to note
first it's important to understand that
per RSA a public hearing is
required whenever SP2 appears on a
warrant in fact in multi- toown
districts such as a Cooperative School
District
hearings need to be held
in in each
town in that Cooperative School District
on different days and the hearings are
typically held 15 to 30 days ahead of
the vote second it's also important to
keep in mind that many voters cannot
attend a meeting
practically to um vote to adopt SP2
these meetings are typically held during
the week in the evenings in March of
Times March has inclement weather it's a
s significant challenge for many voters
um that are elderly or disabled to be
able to get to the meeting location and
participate in an often lengthy meeting
that sometimes runs late into the night
and in some cases they they occur over
many days some voters also have health
concerns and they cannot risk being in a
large gathering at a traditional town
meeting other voters have second shift
overtime and even weekend work
commitments if these um traditional
meetings are held on the weekend and
that this conflicts with their um
ability to attend these the traditional
meeting still others are out of town on
travel for work military service away
from home or they might be snowbirds who
reside out of state all of these voters
are disenfranchised and they want SP2
because it enables their voices to heard
at The Ballot Box I find it ironic that
these citizens cannot make it to the tra
traditional meeting to vote to adopt SP2
which is exactly the meeting system that
would eliminate their
disenfranchisement third adopting s SP2
is a serious
proposition many more voters cast
ballots on Election Day than are able to
attend a traditional meeting I contend
that by placing the question to adopt
SP2 back on to the official ballot this
provides better representation of the
will of the people in the town or the
school district and fourth with at least
44 warrant articles to adopt sb2 since
the 2019 change there is significant
interest by voters to adopt sb2 it's
clear that the current method of sb2 SP2
adoption at the traditional meeting is
truly not fair to disenfranchise voters
therefore I feel that it's just common
sense to return the original method to
adopt SP2 that had been in place for
nearly 25 years before the change in
2019 in conclusion by restoring the
question to adopt SP2 back onto the
official ballot this bill eliminates
voter disenfranchisement and adopting
sb2 this bill enables greater vot of
participation which better represents
the will of the people and this bill
restores Equitable standards to adopt
SP2 as well as to resend it I
respectfully ask that this committee
please recommend a to pass on HB 1175 to
restore the method to adopt SP2 as it
was for nearly a quarter of a century
thank you Mr chairman and I'll answer
any
questions thank you very much
representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing is forward representative
in the first sentence it says
shall sub Vision shall place the
question on the warrant that means
whether or not they Senate Bill two
communities presently they still have to
put it on the warrant and won't that be
confusing thank you um representative so
the language that you're referring to on
line three that is is current um
currently in law that's not what this
bill is doing that's the bill is not
changing that so if uh follow up Mr so
if I'm a Senate bill to community I
don't have to do anything is that
correct
correct representative
PRI thank you for taking my question and
thank you for being here uh what was the
reasoning back in 2019
to revert back to the town meetings for
uh those communities that were wishing
to
become
SP2 thank you for the question
representative um you would have to
pull um the the people um as to what the
rationale
was um a possible explanation would be
that people may have been concerned that
people didn't know what were voting on
when it appeared on the official ballot
and as I pointed out per RSA hearings
are
required whenever SP2 appears on the
warrant and in the case of a like for
example a school district where there's
more than one town that's part of that
school district hearings must be held in
each town and I would further say that
um that there are public hear
well there are other opportunities for
people to get information with regards
to SP2 there's you know a town meeting
like a
regular town meeting of the select board
that issue might come up as I said there
was there's required
hearings there's
um also you know people there's
information that different information
sessions that that I know are held in
different towns there's voters guides um
there's there's many opportunities to
understand what sb2 is and I would
further say that we have um zoning
ordinances that appear on warrants
and people
vote I meant they're on the warrants and
they are voted on the official ballot so
um this is really no
different representative yella
representative Guri could you flick off
your mic there thank you
thank you um thank you for
uh your bringing this bill forward um
have you reached out to any of the
groups like the veterans that have been
disenfranchised by this law change and
um and see if there is an appetite for a
lawsuit against the the
uh the state for disenfranchising them
as far as like they used to be able to
vote on this and now they're not able to
vote on it um that are dep deployed have
you have you reached out to them
regarding the that issue thank you for
the question Representative no I have
not reached out to um veterans groups in
the state with regards to this law
change however as I said the reason why
I filed this bill is because I there's a
number of constituents that
that have asked me to to file this
because of the change that occurred in
2019 and I gave this the data as to when
this change was made since it's been
made only one
um warrant to adopt s SP2 has
succeeded and uh additionally I am part
of a CO op school district and there
this year there is a petitioned warrant
article for um sb2 for the co-op school
district and there is the prime the the
primary petitioner is a disabled
veteran and unfortunately he will be
unable to attend the the meeting the
traditional annual meeting of the school
district to vote on this because of his
disability and and the the prescriptions
that he's on will prohibit him from even
speaking or being able to vote on
SP2 rep
represent thank you Mr chair and thank
you for allowing my
questions
um
as as moderator of an SP2 town
and have been for over 10
years
and the the town voted to adopt the SP2
form of
government long before I was right after
it came out you said 19 was it that it
was
started um several years we've had it's
been on the I don't know there's a
question here somewhere um
we've had petition articles put on to do
away with
it they finally gave up because they got
nowhere absolutely
nowhere uh my question
is what's your experience with
dealing with
SP2 form of
government and
um who pushing to to have it
changed thank you for the question
representative um this bill does not
address the SP SP2 form of government
per se um I'm not here to speak for or
against SP
SP2 what this bill does is it changes um
the method to adopt
sb2 like I said when when in 1995
when this was there was a bill
to enable SP2 T form of of
meeting that the question to adopt the
legislature like I said in its in its
wisdom place the question to adopt on
the official
ballot and then in
2019 there was a bill to to undo
that forther questions
I see none thank representative Guth Ju
Just to follow up I'm I'm still confused
because as I said I'm a sen I'm I'm on a
Senate bill to
town and I think when you I asked you
said I didn't have to do anything and I
would continue as a Senate bill to
town isn't that great thank you for the
question representative SP SP2 is
enabling legislation this is this is SP
2 is not a mandate it's it's optional if
if towns want to put this on towns or
school districts want to put this on
their warrant they can and
furthermore the
legislature
has
passed a law that allows citizens to
also by petition warrant article put SP
SP2 onto the warrant so the governing
body could choose to do that or
petitioners can so I know my qu my
question isn't my question isn't clear
and I I understand I I'm a Senate Bill
too so if this bill passes I don't have
to do anything that is correct if I'm a
Senate Bill two and I choose to put this
article forward in a warrant
article and
it passes
or it doesn't pass where am
I if if if a town or School District
currently has sb2 if they've adopted it
they have SP2 there's no need
to ad it again say somebody wants to
based on this bill I'm I'm confused if
you want to resend it nothing I want to
put it on a ballot so if you already
have to
so it's probably better when we EXA this
bill Mr chairman sorry that would be
good we try not to have uh conversations
here the represent I can talk about it
at that time thank you thank you all
right further
questions I
see representative fra has a question
thank you representative power when the
law was changed in I think you said
2019 do you recall if the vote in
the general house was close Vote or it
passed by an overwhelming
[Music]
margin I I don't have that information
no not not here in my backup information
okay but it it was it got signed into
law
so okay further
questions representative Holland you
look like you have one no oh okay
[Laughter]
thank you for representative power I
have one more pin card Katherine Heck
from
nhma good afternoon members of the
committee Mr chairman for the record my
name is Katherine heck and I represent
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and we are here to oppose um House Bill
1175 so for the record or opposition has
nothing to do with the sb2 form of
government um just as a sponsored said
but rather the procedure a town would
follow to adopt this significant change
in how a government would operate so
while the prior law which this bill
seeks to restore did require a public
hearing on the question to be held 15 to
30 days before the vote we restore that
experience has shown that very few
people generally attend these hearings
it's also important which was brought up
that sb2 can be IED by 25 registered
voters so it would show up on the
petition so I want to go back prior to 2
to law change so prior to 2018 for
example um persistent efforts by some
Pro ballot supporters for example to
pass sb2 in B they rejected it six times
in BO prior to the law change so nothing
to do with it Hinsdale also six
unsuccessful votes nine in sandton and
15 in the town of Temple so prior to the
law change um some of what precipitated
the law change was that uh and there's
testimony in the former record for
example from the town of Temple to say
that it would not allow the form of
government to be changed using the
current form of government that they're
experiencing so to change to sb2 in the
prior law it would be put on the ballot
so there would be you would still go to
your town meeting but you would have
already voted on that question um like
you would do for your zoning ordinance
and it was failing significantly because
many people believe that maybe some
attentive voters were able to um discern
what a yes vote would mean but perhaps
others did not feel that they had the
time or the understanding to debate the
question because they were used to the
annual town meeting form of government
where they would gain and Gardner a lot
of their information from so essentially
um without the ability to debate and
deliberate the question the reason was
that um the what what does a yes ballot
vote mean and they were nervous so let's
just talk about sb2 form of government
for a moment to talk about voters and
making sure no one feels
disenfranchised SP2 form of government
does require that you have public
hearings that you have a deliberative
session prior to your March vote so if
you're worried about the weather for
example you have to have a deliberative
session in February at the deliberative
session it's structured much like an
annual town meeting we have a moderator
here that can can speak to that so that
is when the voters get to come out take
the warrant that's developed by the
governing body and or the budget
committee and change line items zero
them out amend warrant articles or do
anything they would like to do so just
because their sb2 form of government
they they really do still have this
version of town meeting and what happens
at the deliberative session then gets
carried on to the ballot in March
so I personally would not give give up
my right to attend the deliberative
session if I was concerned and wanted to
debate and deliberate the budget so SP2
does not only have a on shot bite at the
Apple in fact it has three bites at the
Apple from the public hearing to the
deliber session to the ballot vote so
when we talk about important questions
um most matters that have a
significant impact on the town go before
a traditional town meeting so again the
change in 20 19 was precipitated by
concerned towns and cities and voters
who felt like being placed on the ballot
they did not have the information they
needed in a new voting in a new form of
government on an old form of government
when we talk about resending the vote it
would be impossible if adopted to resend
um SP2 any other way besides a ballot
vote because they don't have a town
meeting anymore to resend it so that
that probably is not um something to be
concerned um with
um and we always hear from cities and
towns and officials they're always
looking for new tools and ways to
further engage voters and and voter
education so the adoption of sb2 is a
huge decision um placing it on the
ballot basically the language is shall
we adopt the provisions of RSA 403 known
as sb2 to allow official ballot voting
on all issues before the town on the
second Tuesday of March that is the
question you're voting on this does not
describe or communicate to the voters
the nuances of a deliberative session
that doesn't answer questions what the
default budget is which we hear a lot
about how the default budget Works how
it's calculated so or what happens if
the vote the budget is voted down so by
going back to the traditional town
meeting bringing this information
forward and letting the current form of
government decide if it wants to change
the form of government um actually has
resulted in in several communities
adopting the sb2 form of government
since the 20 9 law change but as you can
see from just several towns there was
significant towns rejecting it prior to
the law change as well so I'm not sure
that that is signific you know will make
a significant difference I do also want
to point out in 2019 the house Municipal
and County government committee
recommended the bill 18 to1 to pass the
house voted on division 235 to 1222 to
pass and it was unanimously um approved
by the senate committee and approved by
the Senate on a Voice vote so it had
overwhelming support so that basically
this is really about the voters having
the ability to decide in their current
form of government if they want to
change to another form of government um
in essence so I will leave it with that
I certainly have the record um from 2019
um so we just would like the town
meeting to remain the same and if they
choose to change they do it that the
decision is made in the same manner in
which they're currently operating in
government
um and it's critical for the voter
essentially so I'll take any questions
if you have any and I know it's very
late representative
yella thank you thank you for taking my
question the in my my
municipality um our
sb2 was adopted after multiple
votes um in multiple years of of voting
on the subject and um so I'm a little
bit confused as far as your and and you
and in your testimony you said that
happened in multiple municipalities and
so I'm a little confused as to how
you are squaring the circle that the
municip those people that are voting on
it maybe the verse first time they vote
on it they might be
wary of it and vote no but as they hear
more about it year after year more
people are are convinced and think that
this is a good idea and adopt it and so
I don't you seem to be implying that
those those people that are voting on it
are uneducated but then often it's
actually takes multiple years for it to
pass and so those people that are voting
on it are very educ ated on what that
that uh Pro that question on the ballot
is and so is that really uh the the
education of the voters really the main
concern um as far as the opposition or
is it just um the the town meetings want
to they you know want to be able to peer
pressure those people voting against it
in in by seeing their face and see who's
opposing it and who's is so thank thank
you for your question I think I was just
trying to provide some examples to
counter um the examples in support of
the bill that were saying that towns
couldn't pass it under the law change my
point was towns couldn't pass it prior
to the law change if that's the will of
the voter I would never insinuate voters
are uneducated or don't want to become
educated or that when they come back
year over-year um you know they they're
not more familiar with the topic um
however when you go to the polls it's
really just one sentence that you're
you're voting on um and we do you know
know that new people move in and out of
town and and that changes but certainly
it's really about the town I did want to
bring up that under the current law they
have to the 2019 law change it has to be
done at secret ballot at the town
meeting so your neighbors cannot
pressure you if this is a form of
government that you would like the
current law allows everybody to have the
right to vote privately much like the
old ballot version where you go in the
booth you'd have you go up to The Ballot
Box and you place your card in so you
would not receive that pressure at your
your town meeting with your neighbors
because certainly that would be a
concern with a form of government change
so that's already in the current the
law you have a followup yeah um one of
those towns that just recently um tried
to do this was a town in my district
where they had essentially a
9-hour
uh um town meeting um and the
people advocating for and saying that
this is a good idea or why it's a good
idea or why it's not actually they have
to get up in front of everyone and speak
about it and so that is the opportunity
they do know who is who is opposing it
and who is is is supporting it and
actually it was a selectman in this case
that that put it on the ballot um and so
there was a lot of hostility because of
the people that are on currently
controlling the
selectman being uh trying to like there
was some skepticism just because of that
and so representative could you get to a
question those those there was a lot
would you uh would you be surprised to
find out that the the people that were
putting it Forward were actually created
more hostility towards the the thing
than the actual language of SP2 I would
imagine the same scenario would occur at
a public hearing which is required in
both versions of this bill whichever one
you're considering both require a public
Hearing in that same scenario of
everyone having to speak publicly
Express their
concerns show their positions whichever
they might be would be occurring at at
the public hearing as well of course if
it's petitioned the 25 voter signatures
are available for anyone to consider and
if it's brought forward by the governing
body it's very clear who who would like
to see that that move forward so I think
the public hearing and the town meeting
would be as far as how the public views
it or the debate that occurs would be
very similar okay thank you thank you
further
questions thank you very much for
hanging around till the very end we
appreciate your testimony seeing no more
questions I will go ahead and close the
public hearing on 1175 I'd also like to
thank all the members of the committee
who stuck around to the end very good so
we will see everybody
tomorrow for